I try so hard boom and we're live
Hamilton Morris sober as [ __ ] how about
you absolutely say yes this time so we
did a podcast seven years ago and most
people apparently didn't know how [ __ ]
up we were but I figured damn we're here
with Hamilton Morris
we should go deep and we just kept
hitting that joint till I lost most of
my grasp on reality while we're talking
it's just a very slippery conversation I
was just too high to form coherent
thoughts it was just whatever I pieced
together was just you know it was almost
like miming a conversation uh-huh but
now seven years later and you have a new
place yeah it's beautiful
yeah we you were in the early days we
did it at my house yeah that was way way
way back in the day I had no idea really
I knew you were of course but I didn't
know about your podcast entirely I had
seen clips of you on YouTube and it
wasn't until I was driving home from
that recording and my phone just filled
with hundreds of emails that I realized
oh wow this is a serious phenomenon that
I was not aware of and now I see it's
just become huge it's a weird thing dude
it it's it's got the wheel I just sort
of have to show up it's a very strange
and it sounds like false modesty or
something like that but I'm just being
totally honest like this thing does
itself I think a lot of it might have to
do with the long form begins people are
so used to seeing people's opinions
condensed and filtered into these sound
bites and snippets and to hear an
extended conversation with someone where
they can actually tell stories and
articulate their opinions in a nuanced
careful ways so rare I agree it's one of
the reasons why I don't do those shows
anymore like panel shows and things like
that it's just so frustrating oh it's
insane I have very little experience
with that sort of thing but I did dr. oz
[Laughter]
yes and I don't know how any normal
person could function in that sort of
environment I mean I have a TV show so
arguably I'm
well trained for that sort of thing but
unless you're an actor who's prepared a
line to say as soon as they point at you
there's no way that you could function
because it's not a genuine conversation
it's just an opportunity to launch one
sentence sound bites and an audience
applause
yeah and also the audience is such a
strange element to add to a conversation
I mean if you and I were having this
conversation exactly in this this room
but to the left of us is an enormous
group of people we feel weird we would
have to address them we'd have to turn
to them it would be odd the following
illuminated applause and laughter
science God knows the weirdest when
there's always the warm up guys like
okay ready we're coming back from break
coming back from Craig and they hold up
the side and applause applause applause
and everybody goes crazy and they create
the worst environment I was on this
discussion about crow Tom are you
familiar with this I'm on it right now
oh wow yeah I just took some I [ __ ] my
knee up the other day I did something
and it's been stiff and painful so I I
stood before I came here and then I just
took took six of them see what happens
Wow okay 10 once I don't know can you
grab that bag there's a bag that's
sitting right on the sink I'll tell you
exactly what's in it but now I get why
people might think it's a drug what is
the drug yeah for sure but when I took
four I was like well I took two for the
first time I took it I took two and a
couple times I took two him with this
like a mild stimulant but then when you
get into the range of eight to ten pills
it's like oh this this will [ __ ] you up
this stuff the stuff I take is urban ice
organics and see it says it says take
two it doesn't say the amount of
material in the capsule 750 milligrams
okay so not quite a gram not quite a
grandma all right it seems like a
reasonable amount but they always
construct these things in these
ridiculous dramatic opposition's like it
was me versus a woman whose son had died
of some kratom associated
for DOS and you know it turns into a
thing like what do you have to say to
this woman whose son died it's like I
don't know you know there are people
that die from caffeine overdoses as well
it's tragic that this happened have
people died from this yes they haven't
you have to take an enormous amount I
mean I think a lot of people set up
these unrealistic expectations with
these drugs where they if they like a
drug they want to say it's impossible
right to kill anyone it's impossible
there's no possible way if you said that
is your standard you'll always fail
because people will die doing absolutely
everything running having sex defecating
aspirin aspirin absolutely there's
nothing in this world that can't find
its way into a human death so if people
want to say and even you know cannabis
obviously people say you can't overdose
on cannabis and essentially you can't
but if you look in the medical
literature there are a number of these
cannabis associated fatalities you know
you can debate them endlessly but the
point is once a drug enters a large
enough population
there'll be a number of sensitive
individuals and someone will die it
doesn't mean that the drug is dangerous
it means that it's unrealistic to set a
standard where if anything bad happens
to anyone we have to decide that the
drug is dangerous and should be banned
yeah I agree
I mean look water kills people there's a
lot of these hazing things where the
fraternity kids will be asked to drink a
[ __ ] ton of water and oh yeah the people
have died from it a woman died in San
Jose a few years back from a contest to
drink water to get her son like an Xbox
or something like that yeah yeah I mean
there's a lot of things that are lethal
but the ld50 for cannabis I mean you
literally have to smoke your bodyweight
or something right it's something crazy
be very difficult yeah but it doesn't
mean that you couldn't get so high that
you did something really stupid and wind
up dying right yeah especially dependent
upon the person and the the you know
biological variability right right
exactly and it's just I think it's also
just a sort of a bad road to go down
people always want to emphasize the
safety of things that in my opinion
safety isn't the point
it doesn't ultimately matter to me
whether or not something is safe I think
we should have the freedom to do
dangerous things if we choose
we're allowed to ride motorcycles were
allowed to shoot guns you're allowed to
go skydiving and bungee jumping all
those things carry risks but it's
assumed that any adult that does them is
aware of those risks yeah I couldn't
agree more I mean it's it's also who is
if the society that we live in was just
you and I is that we were the only two
people alive who are you to tell me what
I can do or me to tell you what you can
do it's ridiculous and so when you have
grown adults telling a grown adult who's
informed what they can and can't do then
it becomes a question of children well
then it becomes a an education issue and
it becomes a parental issue I mean it's
just you can't lie to your children
about the effects of certain drugs
because then they're not gonna believe
you about the really actual the actual
dangerous ones
Brayan and this is of course reflected
in the the so-called opioid epidemic yes
right now yes there's endless
finger-pointing everyone wants to find a
culprit that's behind all of it and the
easiest person to blame of course are
pharmaceutical companies because
everybody hates pharmaceutical companies
so why not blame them right but you know
and I'm not Pro pharmaceutical by any
stretch of the imagination but I'm also
not anti pharmaceutical either and when
you look at the way for example the New
York Times is covering the opioid
epidemic it's always in this tone of
like documents were uncovered this show
that executives at Purdue Pharma were
aware that morphine was addictive as
early as 1999 it's like well of course
of course they were aware people have
known that morphine is addictive for
hundreds of years this is old news and
this whole idea that doctors were
convinced by some letter in the New
England Journal of Medicine that said
that oxycontin isn't addictive is absurd
these are all morphine derivatives any
adult especially a medically trained
adult should know that no matter what
little variation you make on that
molecule if it's structurally and
pharmacologically and qualitatively
similar to morphine of course it's going
to be addictive and that in and of
itself isn't even a bad thing it should
be okay to give people addictive drugs
as well as long as everyone's aware of
the risks as long as they understand a
protocol to get off of it the you you
know there's so many people that get on
these things and then wind up taking
them far longer than they're supposed to
because it's easy to get
I mean we need to at least have some
sort of responsible direction that these
people need to go to to get off of them
once they're on them because people that
get back operations any anything where
they prescribe you high doses of opiates
it's a huge problem I know many many
people that have gotten hooked because
and in fact I should tell you that my
good friend Justin Ren his wife found
out about kratom because of you because
of your show he had a problem with his
shoulder got shoulder shoulder surgery
they put him on oxycontin's he was
[ __ ] up on them and he was having a
really hard time getting off and having
the shakes really bad and kratom is the
only thing that got him off of it right
and that's not surprising I mean this
has been known for a very long time in
Thailand and that was actually the
reason that it was originally prohibited
I don't know if you're aware of that but
because the government taxed opium and
people started using kratom then they
made Crotona leaves not the right way to
say it because people say kratom yeah
you're the only one I've heard sacred
Tom people in it's a Thai word people in
Thailand call it critic so people in the
US call it kratom it's a it's also they
have you know is maybe it's a quick Tom
something I'm not gonna go that forever
Cree tom is close if you did it would be
weird but I feel as you know yeah
like American people that say Ecuador
hahahaha Argentina but it is Krita yeah
crow Tom okay so we'll try to call Chris
or something close to that it's closer
to that than kratom right and so the
reason why was made it illegal was
because of the fact that it was pinching
some of the profits off of the opium
trade yes Wow
yeah that's [ __ ] up and so this has
been known for a long time that it helps
people get off more addictive opioids
and how does it do that well it's an
opioid itself and a lot of people don't
want to admit or acknowledge that but I
think we need to get beyond this idea
that drugs are inherently bad or opioids
are inherently bad just because the ones
that we're aware of have a lot of
problems you know in some sense
medicinal chemistry and pharmacology and
all this are still in a very primitive
state and there's so much to be learned
so we're mostly giving people these
derivatives of morphine that have been
around for a hundred years
and there are better things we're going
to continuously discover less addictive
treatments for pain and I think that the
alkaloids in kratom are a step in that
direction and which is so tragic that
they're trying to now make it illegal
because this is something that as far as
I can tell has genuinely helped an
enormous number of people reduce their
intake of more addictive and more
dangerous opioids one of the things that
I felt I mean and again my dose was not
extremely high but when I was on it I
was very coherent I was clear it was
clear to me that was affected by
something but it felt kind of good
it didn't feel bad it felt a little a
little uneasy like a little like whoa
this is what the world feels a little
weird right now
but it did not feel like I was impaired
like I know a lot of people who take it
and exercise like I have a friend he'll
take ten pills and exercise it just just
seems kind of [ __ ] crazy yes but he
says he has a great workout right by
taking that stuff before he works out
yeah I mean it seems to lend itself to a
lot of different applications in
Thailand it's used almost exclusively
for that sort of purpose in the south
it's a drug that labourers use so they
can you know collect it the latex from
rubber trees and just get their job done
that's what it's about I mean that's
what opioids are about for a lot of the
world both in the United States and in
Africa and in Thailand is you know
people live hard lives and manual labor
is painful and repetitive and difficult
and anything that makes that a little
bit more manageable is a very important
tool for humans I always felt like
people that did heroin or opiates or
some point that were on a very short
road to death that that was my
perception when I was a kid and then I
had a friend who was a longshoreman they
worked on the docks bringing they would
bring fish in and fillet the fish for
the market and he worked with a guy that
every day at lunch the guy would go cop
he would get his heroin he would shoot
it up in his car and then he'd go back
to work and I was like he'd go back to
work
you know he kept he worked everyday like
every day shot up and every day he
worked like yeah who's never late
nope just did his work all right Wow
well I didn't think you could do that I
thought you did heroin the next thing
you know you just be on the floor in a
fetal position in your own urine and you
just would fall apart and die right yeah
there's this idea that people sometimes
refer to as pharmacological determinism
that a certain drug has to do a certain
thing so alcohol has to sedate and dis
inhibit you heroin has to addictive and
make you a slave to it and kill you
cocaine has to be a euphoric thing
that's done at parties it's also very
addictive PCP has to make you strip nude
and run around fighting Compton fighting
cops and punching holes and wooden
fences but when you look at this you
know anthropologists have looked at
certain drugs that are used
cross-culturally like alcohol and what
you find is this whole idea of
pharmacological determinism is
fundamentally flawed
drugs behave differently in different
cultures depending on the set and
setting of the user and so you find all
sorts of instances that are major
exceptions to these rules that we've set
up for these various drugs for example
PCP which is arguably one of the most
ubiquitous ly maligned drugs in the
world I mean no one can imagine that PCP
is medicinal but even to this day PCP is
in schedule to not Schedule one like
cannabis and LSD schedule two it can
still be prescribed actually and that's
because it had a history of medicinal
use
there was even PCP psychotherapy in the
UK and in the 50s so this is a something
that most people wouldn't believe but to
those patients that were taking it then
there was none of this cultural
association with PCP being a drug that
causes psychosis or makes you strip nude
it was simply another tool for a
psychiatrist to use and help people
release repressed memories or traumas
that they were afraid to talk about when
sober hmm well we're seeing that now
with MDMA right I mean and also ketamine
ketamine you being used as an actual
tool for psychotherapy particularly for
people with depressions having really
good results my my friend hmm
excuse me Neal Brennan who's a hilarious
comedian he's had struggles with
depression yeah he got great relief from
from taking ketamine right and what I
think is really interesting is you know
this is often packaged as a sort of
psychedelic Renaissance but I think in a
larger context it's a drug facilitated
psychotherapy Renaissance because this
was not just limited to psychedelics
people did something called narco
analysis where they would give people
sedatives like propofol the drug that
killed Michael Jackson or various
barbiturates or various other drugs and
the relaxing effect would allow people
to talk more openly to a therapist and
it was considered very effective now
this idea of a psychiatrist injecting
you with a drug in order to help you
talk about your problems is it's unheard
of I don't think anyone does it anymore
but it used to be very common and I
think a return to that is going to be
really beneficial yeah I agree with you
I think the right drugs with the right
cases and the right people and I think
we've got to get past these schedules
that when you have things like marijuana
and psilocybin and and especially DMT
which your own body produces is a
Schedule one drug and the famous Terence
Mckenna line we're all holding you know
when it comes to DMT it's just stupid
it's just it's stupid that these things
are Schedule one when you're saying
there's no medical benefit whatsoever or
medical application for cannabis it's
[ __ ] crazy
when something didn't you want to have
something that really actively promotes
a distrust in law enforcement the
scheduling of drugs is one of the best
ones because when you look at something
like marijuana and you see that that's a
Schedule one drug that that that's
infuriating to people that gain huge
benefits from cannabis I mean people
that have going through chemotherapy
people that have you know inter ocular
pressure from glaucoma you can go down
the list over and over and over again
maybe kids that have epilepsy there's so
many people that have
had great benefit particularly from
edible cannabis from people that have
seizures I mean you could keep going on
and on and on it's just it's an amazing
plant and to have that demonized because
of some ridiculous propaganda from the
1930s that still somehow or another
clung on and 2018 you think about all
the information we have now with the
Internet and the fact that cannabis is
still scheduled one you have [ __ ]
like Jeff Sessions
still saying things like good people
don't smoke marijuana like this is crazy
talk it's crazy but keep in mind it was
just about a hundred years ago that
alcohol was prohibited in United States
and it took 13 years to reverse that and
that was alcohol there's no drug more
integrated into our culture than alcohol
and that took 13 years to reverse what
was that like back then that must have
been madness when alcohol was illegal
when the cops would come in and
jackbooted thugs would knock over gin
mills and bust open kegs of whiskey and
spill it all out like what the [ __ ] was
that like it was it was disastrous but I
think what's interesting about that is
it was a worthwhile experiment to give
them the benefit of the doubt it was
worthwhile to see because on some sense
you could say the prohibition has a
certain logic to it you could say drugs
cause problems so if we just make all
the drugs illegal then maybe those
problems will disappear mm-hmm but it
didn't work the experiment failed and
there's nothing wrong with a failed
experiment but it's a problem if you
keep repeating it over and over and over
again for a hundred years looking for a
different result right and then go to
other drugs and go well this one let's
try this one let's make this one illegal
and it's a terrible PR situation for the
police as well if I were a police
officer I would be the biggest opponent
of the war on drugs and of anyone in the
government because when you think about
why does the average person in New York
City love a firefighter
they love firefighters but they hate
cops why is that it's because of the
drug war because a firefighter isn't
going to hurt you for something that
wasn't really a crime to begin with for
some kind of victimless crime a
firefighter is just there to help you to
save you if you're in trouble and the
same would be true of police officers if
it weren't
the drug war ideally there's a little
more complexity to it sure this sermon
certainly more complexity when it comes
to shootings and yes but I mean the stop
and frisk I've read something about stop
and frisk in New York when they had when
they add that instituted that most of it
was drugs most of it was like catching
people with marijuana yeah which is just
[ __ ] insane you just study you look
like you might be streetwise get over
here
and that's the way these laws have
functioned from the very beginning I
mean if you look at drug law in the UK
it tends to be very black-and-white
something is legal or illegal if it's
legal it can be sold in stores because
it's legal if it's illegal it can't be
sold anywhere in the US they've instead
created this nebulous far-reaching gray
area where there's all sorts of things
that are maybe illegal kind of illegal
do it but don't get caught and and it's
created an ability for the government to
selectively prosecute people whenever
they want if they want mmm yeah well
that seems to be lessening I mean when
you have someone like Jeff Sessions in
office it's very disturbing but then
Trump says things like he's very strong
on states rights to you know past
marijuana laws and things along those
lines you know you're very incredulous I
don't know I mean I suppose I am a bit
incredulous when it comes to Trump doing
anything good but I think if you told
him that people love him more if he did
things good he would do things good
that's probably true
I think someone that he trusted said -
yeah I think that's is more I think
we've got to get somebody in deep we got
to get them all and got to get somebody
who's good at backrubs it gets by I
[Laughter]
doubt it up I mean just I don't know
what is the thing that will help there's
also the separation between the drug
users and the policy makers yes and and
one thing that I am certain will help
and it's sort of tragic that this is the
case but it's capitalism it's the
corporatization of these drugs because
with cannabis you know when it was
hippies in the counterculture had
you know marches down the streets of New
York holding up 420 signs it doesn't I
suppose have all that much clout in the
eyes of lawmakers but when you have some
guy from Yale Business School who's
never smoked weed who says you know this
is a serious business opportunity yeah
we're gonna make it big and gets
investors invests millions and millions
of dollars into it hires lobbyists plays
the game like a capitalist then the laws
do change and I wish that weren't the
case but it is and it's tragic for the
people that did fight and did go to
prison and did sacrifice that then these
these business school guys come along
and reap all the benefits but that's the
way it works yeah that is the way it
works and that's okay I mean it's just a
weird path it's a weird path but as long
as we can get to legalization I'm a
hundred percent for that path I just
think that might be the only way in this
weird country this country is so
enamored with money I mean we're so
enamored with money and profits and even
for dying people even old like Warren
Buffett invested [ __ ] tons of money in
warehouses to sell ket to to grow
cannabis in Colorado when the laws are
passed I mean that guy's a hundred and
fifty thousand years old he's worth
billions of dollars and he's like who
gives a [ __ ] I'm making more money now
and more and more and more I mean even
when they're really old they're they're
massively motivated by profit yes and I
think the same will be true for
psychedelics and will probably be true
for all of these things because you need
to have lobbyists you need to have this
sort of typical white-collar support to
push things forward mm-hmm I agree I
don't see any other way around it right
now I mean the real hope is that
cannabis not that it will get rid of
capitalism but that we'll figure out
it's hard to wear those things with
glasses on right yes they always talking
about it the glasses dig in your head
that cannabis will the
not just cannabis but cannabis will open
the door to all these different
substances that'll allow people to have
a to gain a greater perspective this is
the ultimate goal in my opinion is to
give people the opportunity to step
outside the momentum of their lives and
look at things with fresh eyes and make
clear decisions this is a one of the
best things that I think that drugs
provide is that these psychedelic drugs
in particular provide an escape from the
momentum of this life that you've
created or that you found yourself a
part of it's very difficult for people
to stop behavior patterns to stop and to
just look at themselves objectively and
sort of rethink regroup and reassess and
this is one of the best things about
cannabis and about psilocybin and a lot
of these other psychedelic drugs is that
it gives you this newfound perspective
that allows you to reconsider things yes
absolutely and I think with you know
ketamine and the treatment of depression
it's a similar idea because depressed
people become used to these very
ingrained patterns of thinking and
anything that can break you out of that
that can shake it up for a minute and
maybe give you a different perspective I
think is inherently therapeutic yeah I
think so as well and I think I'm hoping
that what I see and this is what I
believe I see is that we're changing our
perceptions of it I had a conversation
with a friend of mine the other day
about marijuana where we were talking
about how you used to hide whether or
not you did it from certain people and
now that group of people that you have
to hide it from is smaller and smaller
and that it seems like everyone casually
smokes marijuana now in in our circles
there's so many people to do there's a
few that don't sober people and whatever
but it's way more common whereas 10-15
years ago this was something you hid if
you had a good job if you had a family
there's not something you wanted people
to know about and what I think is really
interesting is that in and of itself
changes the nature of the cannabis
experience so I think if somebody uses
cannabis in a culture that supports it
that approves of it their experience
will be better by virtue of that fact
right so
there's a certain shame that a lot of
people feel when using any drug I for
whatever crazy reason feel it a little
bit with cannabis it's you know a little
just a hair of I should be you know I
should be studying should be reading it
should be you know more focused this is
a little hedonistic it's a little
comfort oriented I should be working
harder but that's I think just the
vestiges of this propaganda that I've
been fed or something like that or maybe
it's true but I understand from one
perspective why the cannabis culture
drums the benefits of cannabis so hard
you know that a cures all disease that
it's good for you that a cures cancer
all the stuff because if you have that
in your mind at the very least it's
going to reduce that sort of internal
shame that you might feel it makes the
entire experience healthier and more
beneficial because we do construct these
limitations we construct these
experiences to some extent so if you
decide that cannabis is a dissociative
drug that's hedonistic and
comfort-oriented and will take you away
from your responsibilities and that's
what it will become but if you decide
like Terence Mckenna did that it's an
intellectual catalyst that it will
facilitate your ability to read and
learn and think and write then it will
become that as well
yeah it's it's a weird one right because
people that are people that take it that
are prone to paranoia or that are
dealing with like some difficult issues
in their life right now that they're
perhaps trying to avoid it becomes an
uncomfortable experience whereas people
that are happy and having a good time
and in a good place the marijuana will
sort of enhance that give it as loving
warm feeling of comfort and of like sort
of acceptance of your existence and it's
going to be okay right but I think even
the paranoia is like it's sort of
sort of meme you could say a sort of
vestige of this propaganda that makes
people afraid in the same idea van is
the bad trip I think the concept of a
bad trip is a very damaging concept
because and I know from personal
experience I never really used
psychedelics in high school with the
exception of salvia because I was
terrified of a bad trip
I talked to friends who'd described bad
trips and they say oh it's a it's a bat
it's bad trip it's really bad it's scary
and I would think oh that's terrible I
could I would never want a bad trip I'm
never gonna touch these things because a
bad trip would be too much for me to
tolerate and then I started using
psychedelics and I realized there's no
such thing as a bad trip any more than
there's a bad meal or a bad relationship
or a bad day I mean having an occasional
bad thing in life doesn't stop you from
doing things like eating or having
relationships or living typically so
what do you mean by there's are you
saying there's no such thing as a bad
trip yes there's no such thing as a bad
meal I'm saying that there is such thing
as a bad meal but but it wouldn't
prevent you from tripping and I think
that even the bad or wouldn't bring you
from eating rather sorry about it but
but I think even these bad trips
although they can be difficult are
beneficial and our learning experience
in the same way that a bad meal could be
you learn not to go to that restaurant
or maybe you learn something about what
makes you sick or what to be careful of
in the future you know if you are
approaching life from a non fearful
perspective where your intention is to
learn then you can extract benefit from
almost any experience and these
difficult psychedelic experiences I
genuinely believe and this is what is
maybe the hardest thing to communicate
about psychedelics is that it's the
difficult ones that are often the best
those are the ones that really teach you
something and when you were trying to
talk about psychedelics with people
who've never used them it's not a great
selling point to say oh you know the
best thing that can happen is you're
gonna think you're gonna die but that is
arguably the best thing that can happen
I used to think that you're going to die
because that's a confrontation with the
overarching fear the fear that generates
all other fears and if you conquer that
fear then your life will almost
certainly improve well what is one thing
that's sort of genuine genuinely
universally accepted as a beneficial
experience is a near-death experience
sort of universally accepted as a
transformative moment in people's lives
like I had this near-death experience
and I realized wow I got to get my [ __ ]
together after that heart attack I
realized that life is a gift and I
changed the way I think about things and
I started calling people that I loved
and telling them that I love them this
is the same you can get a near-death
experience from cannabis you just don't
ever die you really do I mean it's the
death of so many perceptions and so many
things about your life especially from a
durable cannabis which i think is
probably one of the least understood and
most potent things that people are
consuming on a daily basis I can't tell
you how many times I've given someone
edible marijuana and they're [ __ ]
convinced that it's been laced with
something awful and that they're going
to die but then afterwards they come out
of it and they're like oh I got some
work to do the only way I would disagree
with you is people that are prone to
psychotic breaks yeah yeah because that
there there's a absolute genuine
connection between people who have a
slippery hold on reality and some
experiences with psychedelics that lead
them down a bad road that's true it can
it's a stressor and like all stressors
it can precipitate a psychotic break
they've done pretty large-scale
epidemiological analyses of psychedelic
drug users versus the non psychedelic
drug using population and the incidence
of mental illness isn't any higher so I
don't think that you can argue that
psychedelics cause mental illness but
you can and some measures it seems to
actually reduce it in terms of things
like alcoholism substance abuse
disorders but but it can be a stressor
that would precipitate such an episode
in a susceptible individual and I had a
very traumatic informative experience
myself for my best friend had a
psychotic break while I was with him
tripping so I've seen this firsthand I
know exactly what it looks like yeah
I've had friends have real bad
experiences to where they're screaming
and yelling and then disassociative and
then afterwards become
very strange and have a really hard time
with reality for a bit yeah I've never
seen someone have a complete psychotic
break this was that he never recovered
never he never recovered he was my best
friend at the time and he never
recovered so he was fine before the
psychedelic yes Jesus Christ slide again
you know it's and that happened early so
now he's still [ __ ] yes but again you
know I typically don't tell that story
in public because it's it could be
misinterpreted as a scare story you know
I don't it's impossible to prove the
counterfactual would it have happened
without psychedelics almost certainly I
can't say all I know is that he took a
very high dose of a Scylla semester and
had this episode he was hospitalized and
he was not the same afterwards so I'm
aware that this is a something that
happens but it also typically happens in
the early 20s late teens the same time
that people typically have psychotic
breaks and develop schizophrenia
yeah the instances of schizophrenia in
people who use cannabis are cannabis in
particular but I don't know about other
psychedelics but I would imagine they're
very similar they're exactly the same as
the incidences of schizophrenia in non
using populations it's like 1% 1%
across-the-board seem to have issues
with schizophrenia and there the real
question is how many of those people
could I mean is it avoidable like if
your friend had never done that and
instead had you know become a marathon
runner or something and you know found
some other outlets for his energy would
he have never gone down that road we
don't know it's impossible yes it's
impossible so I think it's very
important to talk about that though and
with further research perhaps we could
isolate genes you know like they have
for CTE now they have they can do an
analysis of your genes and then
determine whether or not something like
football would be a dangerous path for
you because you have a higher
probability of developing CTE it would
be wonderful if they figured out a way
to do that with psilocybin or
with cannabis or with anything else and
be able to recognize the potential links
to psychotic breaks and to you know a
host of different mental disorders that
could possibly be triggered by high
doses yes I mean this is one of so many
things that needs to be done and that's
you know everyone's very excited about
all this clinical research that's
happening right now I'm excited about it
as well
but on one level it is very politically
oriented research you know the the
things that they're looking at have
actually typically been done before not
all of it but the aim is to firmly
establish these things that have been
known for a long time psilocybin
occassions mystical type experience or
MDMA is useful for treating PTSD or
psilocybin has an anti addictive effect
these are things that people have known
for a little while but now it's about
proving it but I'm really looking
forward to getting deeper into these
serious questions about you know exactly
how these drugs interact with various
subtypes of serotonin receptors because
I think that they're going to be very
important tools for understanding
consciousness as a whole yeah it would
also be interesting knowing how they
react to different diets you know when
people are you know when you're eating
certain types of foods that are bad for
your body I would really be curious to
see what kind of effect that has I mean
when when you have real large-scale
research that goes over really important
variables in terms of a human health and
then you add in these different
substances whether it's psilocybin or
cannabis or whatever it is it's it's
gonna be interesting to see how the body
reacts to these various perturbance iziz
various changes of your state yeah
and that's you know traditionally in a
lot of these indigenous groups the diet
plays a big role in the way that the
drug is administered and I think we're
slowly rediscovering a lot of things
that have been known for tens maybe
hundreds maybe thousands of years in
some of these indigenous groups have you
had a chance to see any of my new show
when
no no I haven't oh you I think you'd
like it I'm sure I'd like it I look at
old show yeah I think it's a lot better
than yeah yeah awesome yeah but I you
know I had the opportunity to look at
the way salvia is used in the mountains
of Oaxaca and you know Native American
peyote use and all these different
things and yeah that there's so much to
be learned from all these traditions
that are not reflected in the current
clinical climate because they can't be
but I think that that's gonna be a part
of it is slowly integrating these other
alkaloids that are present in the plants
to see what role they play in the same
way that you know the initial
medicalization of cannabis was Marinol
which is just THC and sesame oil but now
there's increased understanding of the
way these accessory cannabinoids
modulate the THC experience or whether
THC is even the primary therapeutic
agent for certain disorders and I
imagine the same thing will be true for
peyote and for the iboga alkaloids and
probably even for some of the chemicals
found in mushrooms so when you're doing
this show have you had any problems have
you had any pushback against what you're
doing or any any issues with it being on
vice I've had an enormous amount of
freedom you know ultimately I have very
very little to complain about when it
comes to censorship there was the way
the show got started the actual TV show
is sort of an interesting story where
they were starting up vice land and a
producer who's now gone gave me this
deck of drug stories they were gonna do
in they're all kind of terrible scare
stories like the new drug
bromo-dragonfly it's killing teens a new
drug promo driver Romeo yeah yeah what
is that it's a really fascinating
compound developed by this chemist David
Nicholls who found that that these
conformational e constrained benzo fear
an amphetamine derivatives are like very
high potency dob derivatives anyway it's
just it's a super potent psychedelic
amphetamine that has a cool tricyclic
structure huh
it looks like a dragonfly the molecule
looks like a dragonfly kind of and
it's got a very high yes it's super
super potent and very very long-lasting
so it lent itself to scare stories you
know people it's a potent
vasoconstrictor so people would take
very high doses of it and occasionally
they would have to amputate it
oh there's finger or something like that
but again you know this isn't because
the drug is bad it's because people used
it irresponsibly and this is something
that people have so much difficulty
understanding we're so eager to blame
drugs for all of our problems drugs have
never hurt anyone they're just inanimate
constellations of carbon and hydrogen
nitrogen and oxygen they don't jump out
of their bags and vials and attack your
serotonin receptors or dopamine
transporter or anything like that so
this is just a weird pattern that we've
done repeatedly over time and I don't
know if you read the new Michael Pollan
book I know he was on the podcast I mean
right now yeah it's great
yeah it is great but one thing that I
thought was interesting about it is that
he put a lot of the emphasis on the
prohibition of psychedelics on Leary and
Leary almost certainly played a role but
I think it's slightly ironic that he's a
journalist and didn't really go that
deep into the role that journalists
played in all of this which was
humongous you know journalists are
sculptors of public opinion and it
became the standard way of reporting on
any of these things to say that they're
bad to sensationalize it and to not have
any consideration for what that would do
because any time a journalist writes
some scare story they can really mess
with drug policy in a serious way it
might seem like nothing like oh there's
a bunch of people in Brooklyn and they
overdosed on some obscure synthetic
cannabinoid amb foo bhinneka who cares
about amb foo bhinneka no big deal say
that it turns people into zombies and if
it gets thrown into schedule one who
cares not a big deal well that's a very
short-sighted way of thinking about all
of this because that's exactly what
happened with psychedelics and then
we're not learning from the mistakes of
the past that just because something
it's fun to sensationalize and talk
about how dangerous it is at this moment
doesn't mean that 10 years from now
we're gonna recognize it it has
therapeutic potential and we made a big
mistake outlawing it and I think a lot
of that also comes from this sort of us
versus them mentality that people have
where it's cannabis is good synthetic
cannabinoids are bad
well synthetic cannabinoids don't have
to be bad for cannabis to be good
cannabis can be good without something
else being bad to counterbalance it you
don't need to hate something to justify
your love of cannabis and this whole
hatred of synthetic cannabinoids I think
is totally misdirected because these are
products of prohibition that most people
wouldn't even want to use in the first
place and when they do use them they
don't know what they're taking they
don't know what dose they're consuming
and so of course they're having bad
experiences that would happen with
almost any drug caffeine included if
people just consumed enormous unmeasured
doses without having any idea of what
they were getting into and so they're
thrown into Schedule one well what
happens if 30 years from now once the
therapeutic potential of cannabinoids is
being really seriously explored we find
out that that amb Phu bhinneka that
everyone was saying turned homeless
people into zombies in Brooklyn in 2017
turns out to activate a certain subtype
of the cb1 receptor that's especially
useful for Parkinson's disease or
something like that then we're going to
regret having done that so I think
people have to be very careful anytime
you say anything negative about a drug
you have to be very very careful because
the implications can be enormous I think
that the best stance in all this is to
not speak ill of drugs true drug
enthusiasts but it's not a problem also
with just what journalism is it's like
asking a comedian to talk about
something but not make fun of it that's
what their job in in a certain sense is
to get people excited about things and I
don't know whether you'd say the lazy
way out or the common approach is to say
something that scares people I mean
that's that's what clickbait is mostly
about either outrage or fear that's true
but there's a lot of richness in truth I
agree but it's hard to sell it's hard to
sell that religion hard to sell I think
the people are lazy you know why is this
idea that a lot of people have that you
know journalism is organized by some
malevolent Rupert Murdoch type puppeteer
who's telling everyone to you
often you say that cannabis causes car
accidents right you go off and you say
this evil thing about this and say the
alcohol is good did you see when Alex
Jones is on my podcast and got high with
me drunk and I and when it came up in
his trial for his divorce he said that
George Soros puts a heat test marijuana
every year to see how much George Soros
is influencing the levels of THC people
love these ideas in the ideas of the
puppeteer and malevolent puppeteer
because it denies individual agency but
the reality and I say this as a
journalist who's worked at many
different publications not just vice is
and this is a difficult reality to
swallow is that people are free to say
whatever they want most of the time and
the journalists choose to report on
things this way yeah that is true but
it's also true that they like I've been
a part of stories that where I've talked
to the author of it and they said well
this was manipulated by the editor the
editor manipulated the title the change
was a great excuse yeah another
perspective but at the right but it's
true like the Rolling Stone did an
article about me and they called me a
psychedelic warrior and I said to the
guy who wrote down what the [ __ ] is that
I was laughing and he goes dude I did
not write that yeah
an editor gets a hold of it tries to
make it more salacious it becomes
something that's more it's more likely
for people to buy or click right
especially with headlines that is that
is true and the real problem is that
this sort of outrage culture and comment
culture that has emerged provides no
incentive for truth because suppose
someone were to write an article about
this conversation we're having right now
and it could say Hamilton Morris says
kratom should be illegal or something
like that then that will get so much
more engagement because then you'll have
all these people saying [ __ ] Hamilton
Moore he's a he's a traitor how dare he
say that it should be illegal that it
didn't watch it and then you'll have
other people arguing those people saying
well listen to the interview hey he
actually never said anything about that
listen carefully to what he was saying
and then you create this whole
engagement a bigger engagement for doing
the
long thing then you'd get for doing the
right thing true but the initial
statement is much stickier the initial
statement of Hamilton Morris is a bad
guy because he thinks kratom should be
illegal or khatam should be illegal
that is what more people are going to
pay attention to far less people read
the retraction than read the initial
arse this is one of the more insidious
things about printing things that are
patently untrue purposely that people do
do things that are untrue with the
caveat that they could just print a
retraction that maybe 30% of the people
that read the original article are gonna
read the initial imprint is what's gonna
stick with people even if you someone
calls you a rapist okay and then it
turns out that the person who called
your rapist was lying the people heard
you were rapists first they still have
that in their head oh he's a rapist
greatest right it's just it's very
difficult to get slippery ideas out of
people's head so if somebody writes some
article saying that you're against the
legalization of certain drugs and they
they start looking at you as being
compromised it's the influence that
people have today can't be understated
because the reach is so powerful the
reach of any article any video any it's
it's so significantly greater than any
other sort of distribution of
information in the history of human
beings the the potential for it
impacting large groups of people is so
huge now yes and this is the result of
that is also that the viewers have a lot
of power and I think that in some sense
they don't quite recognize the nature of
that power
it's like voting with your dollar if you
spend all of your time commenting
hatefully on things you don't like you
are actively encouraging the production
of more of that thing that you don't
like right if you like something you
need to engage with what you approve of
more because every time you engage with
something you dislike advertisements are
sold and it has been incentivized to do
that bad thing and that's a really
sticky thing when we have this culture
where everyone loves to out show their
outrage and virtue signal and show that
they're on the right side and all this
stuff constantly to say hey step back
you're just feeding
the problem yeah I think there's also a
problem with a lot of what people are
doing during the day is something they
don't want to do a lot of what people
are doing is some job that they don't
enjoy and during that job they have
freedom to go online and in this state
of feeling like [ __ ] about whatever
they're doing they'll enjoy complaining
about stuff and so they'll read things
and type things and get engaged in
things and there's some sort of a sport
to getting pissed off about stuff
instead of just spending your time doing
things you actually enjoy it seems so
simple it sounds like a simple solution
but if you could figure out a way to
actively ignore things that are gonna
piss you off and seek out things are
gonna excite you and intrigue you you're
gonna be a healthier happier person and
doesn't that isn't that ultimately what
everybody wants I want to be happier
don't you want to be happier of course
but why do we seek out [ __ ] that pisses
us off because it becomes a sort of
addiction yeah it's drug like in and of
itself I mean I see it these arguments
these people are frittering away their
finite time on earth engaged in these
endless comment battles that no one
reads and and it's a very dark reality
but it is also something that's driving
the current culture of journalism that
where the truth doesn't matter as much
all the matters is engagement right
right it's just clicks it's just clicks
and money it's interesting that you were
saying something about drugs being
inanimate objects and drugs don't
actually kill people it's so funny how
drug enthusiasts parallel gun
enthusiasts with their arguments it's
really the same freedom argument and
it's really and I'm in an interesting
perspective because I live in New York
I'm like a whatever just a nerdy guy
that doesn't let me guess you live in
Williamsburg I do yes yeah big surprise
that's for the office though I live
close to the office that I work at but
but you know I have no interest in guns
I'm not so it's really easy for me to
say well look there was this the
shooting and all these people died right
and and this other guy got shot and
these things are really causing a lot of
problems let's get rhythm because
doesn't impact me and that's where you
have to be the most careful because that
the worst thing you can possibly do is
make judgments about how other people
should conduct their lives based on your
own preferences which people do all the
time so you hear someone said well I
don't like cannabis I don't like it I
don't smoke it why should it be legal
because people go to prison for it
because it ruins people's lives who
aren't your own you have to think about
people that aren't you and so it's very
difficult when it comes to gun control
issues because this I'm faced with that
exact same issue where it would be so
easy for me to say get rid of them all
it doesn't impact me I don't like guns
but I don't want to fall into that same
trap yeah it is a trap
and it's it also sort of highlights how
slippery life is in general that these
absolutes that we look for these ones
and zeros they don't necessarily exist
in a lot of subjects you know there's
there's a lot of people that have done
bad things that have also done great
things and that gets weird too you know
it just human beings in general where
we're not we're complex creatures you
know and to just categorize something as
negative or positive it's there's a lot
of positive things that you could find
with drugs there's a lot of negative
things you could find with drugs too and
they mirror human behavior there's a lot
of positive and negatives in human
behavior yes and back to this
journalistic issue in the coverage of
drugs I mean one thing that worries me
about the way cannabis and kratom and
psychedelics are presented is that it's
always couched and they're safe their
therapeutic their spiritual their
historical but that isn't the point even
if all those things are true and there's
some debate eventually someone will find
a [ __ ] in that armor someone will die
maybe they're not haven't been used as
long as you thought they were used maybe
they don't always work therapeutically
so then what do you go back to
prohibition no that's why I think you
need to emphasize cognitive Liberty you
need to emphasize people's right to
explore these alternate states of
consciousness regardless of whether or
not they're therapeutic or safe or
traditional or spiritual the point isn't
that it's safe or any of these other
things the point is that if you want to
live in a free society you have to be
allowed
to take a certain amount of risk yeah
that's that's a big point that's a very
big point and and I think it really it
fits well with your description of the
things that people are allowed to do
that
are legal that are very dangerous like
race car driving bungee jumping all
these things that we just allow them to
do we don't think twice about it using a
parachute
all that crazy [ __ ] we just openly up
saying hey we should ban skydiving
there's no one saying that but [ __ ] a
lot of people die skydiving man I mean
it's it's a [ __ ] dangerous pursuit we
don't seem to care we seem to care about
drugs because we think that somehow or
another either our children or someone
we know is going to be insidiously
infected with these things they're going
to get into their lives and and [ __ ]
them up you know and I think the real
problem with that is education that's
the real problem with that I was
extremely fortunate in a weird way to
see someone with a cocaine addiction
when I was in high school was a good
friend's cousin who got really [ __ ] up
on cocaine when he was a couple years
older than me and I watched his life
fall apart and I remember thinking when
I was little like wow I don't want to
touch that [ __ ] like cocaine is [ __ ]
terrible and then from then on I've
never done cocaine but it's because of
that education because of and I think
real education is something it's a
[ __ ] tough thing because you don't
really just get it from knowing
information you have to see things you
have to talk to people you have to
experience things in your own if someone
talks about psychedelics someone teaches
about psychedelics but they have no
experience in actual psychedelic States
personally it's a very hollow
conversation it's like a certain amount
of education has to be from real-life
experience oh yeah absolutely and the
other thing is just again this idea of
pharmacological determinism like I had a
friend that was very very very seriously
addicted to cocaine and had the
resources to do immense quantities every
single day and he'd always say well you
know if I try heroin I know it's all
over for me I know that will be the last
straw so I'm never touching that stuff
and he didn't but my own perspective you
know I've essentially tried everything
and if you really just think about these
things you can actually learn for
example I've tried heroin once I didn't
think was that interesting did you do it
injecting no nor did I snorted a yeah
yeah what was it like it was boring
I think orange yeah I don't think
opiates are very interesting drugs
psychologically you know if I were to be
totally honest I think the cannabis is
more euphoric and has so few side
effects you know opiates cause horrible
constipation that cause all kinds of
weird sweating problems I don't think
they're especially Pleasant drugs but
they romanticize so much in our culture
that people think that's it heroin the
ultimate high well maybe it isn't maybe
it's not even that great at all maybe
it's garbage and it doesn't even matter
and that's the same way I feel about
snorted cocaine I don't even think it's
a good drug it's not an issue of it's so
addictive you've got to stay away from
it because it's so damn good it's not
good it's not even an enjoyable high it
has a short duration it you then feel
bad almost immediately afterwards it's a
flawed substance same is true of alcohol
I think as well alcohol is a crazily
flawed molecule it's terrible no other
drug that I can think of causes a
hangover of that type where there's a
toxic metabolite that poisons you the
following day dr. Karl Hart was trying
to explain to me what that is and
essentially he was saying that when you
are getting a hangover it's your body
reacting to the addictive properties of
alcohol that you're getting addicted to
alcohol almost almost immediately that
your body is compensating for that and
then these this this this hangover is
not just you being dehydrated it's also
your body withdrawing from alcohol I
would I am not familiar with any
evidence for that
no yes dr. Corsi actually tried to in
brilliant for him when I first moved he
loved that guy yeah I have a lot of
respect for him but I mean there's a I'd
have to look at his source for that
you'd have to also listen look at the
way I described it because I probably
butchered it
okay but there's an alternate
explanation that's even simpler which is
simply that alcohol is metabolized into
a chemical
acetaldehyde that's toxic so and with
alcohol it's a very very weak drug by
weight you're consuming insane amounts
in terms of the number of molecules
you're in consuming insane quantities of
the drug
so all this acetaldehyde accumulates in
your body and it has a directly toxic
effect is there a way to counteract that
and mitigate the effects yes there are
proposed ways to do it I haven't
experimented with any of them myself
because they don't really like alcohol
that much to begin with
is in glutathione that's a that's
something that allows your body to
process it more easily it would have to
be something that prevents this specific
conversion I don't know off the top of
my head a car what about crocodile you
ever [ __ ] with that stuff well this is
another perfect example so you take a
drug like crocodile and it's it sounds
horrible so the Internet's drugged you
have fear drug yet people are but behind
every scare story
there's nothing if you blame what that
is okay so there's a scare story that I
believe it was in Moscow somewhere in
Russia and it was hitting the news
around 2004 no no much later 2000
10 something like that I don't know and
and the idea was that this is the war
stuff it's ultra addictive you inject it
and then you lose a limb and you have
profound necrosis all around the
injection site and this is the worst
drug most addictive drug of all time
well the drug itself is called des Eaux
morphine and it's been used medicinally
there's nothing especially addictive or
dangerous at all about des a morphine
the problem is that people were
injecting completely impure reaction
mixtures that had all of the components
from the synthesis that hadn't been
removed including phosphorus which is
immensely toxic so you have people
basically reporting on IV phosphorous
toxicity as if it were a result of this
drug when it's a completely separate
issue and this is what you see when you
look at all of these things it's never
the drug any drug scare story it's never
the drug you always have to look for the
root cause because it's never the drug
there's never been a drug in history and
that is why if you look at the DEA 's
list of controlled substances it's not
dangerous drugs that are controlled it's
enjoyable drugs something like
tetrodotoxin the chemical and pufferfish
that's not a controlled substance
there's some regulations in terms of how
much you can purchase but it's not a
controlled substance
Sego toxin the most potent known
neurotoxin it's not a controlled
substance lead is in a controlled
substance mercury is in a controlled
substance mercuric chloride is in a
controlled substance all of the deadly
poisons cyanide is in a controlled
substance it's not about what's safe and
what's dangerous it's about what people
like to use what's enjoyable what is the
root of that
I think it's you know a puritanical idea
that that any sort of euphoria is bad
and you forea is listed as a side effect
in some medications we we assume that
it's a bad thing diarrhea
it's like euphoria diarrhea yeah yeah
that is a strange thing like that's
gonna it's gonna cut back productivity
and make you a lazy near dwell and just
become a burden on society that's that's
a common way of describing people use
drugs sure and this fundamental idea
that sobriety is good yes you look on
Instagram people post a selfie and say
six months sober guys thank you so much
and tons of congratulations because it's
a virtue because you accomplish
something you're not using drugs yeah
whereas in other cultures that would not
be the case people would just say oh
you've decided not to work with a
certain medicine that it's an
interesting choice not an accomplishment
no who was saying was it
Kyle Kingsbury that was saying that how
much he hates the term plant medicine or
was it Dennis thing was tile you don't
like the term plant medicine do I don't
you well do you by there's a it's a
weird sort of pretentious yes yes I know
what people call ayahuasca the medicine
or things like that yeah or tows
medicine I mean I wouldn't you don't
hate it I a lot of these like more
flowery terms like entheogen and I just
don't use them myself but I don't hate
it
well you're you know I think people like
you were very important and I'm a big
fan but I think one of the reasons why
you're important is you are a
cognoscenti of real drugs like you you
understand what they actually do you
could explain them to the layman or you
could debate them with someone who was a
doctor perhaps that wanted to you know
to talk about the dangers of them and
you understand all the various aspects
of it and I think there's a tremendous
amount of ignorance when it comes to
drugs drug consumption what is a drug I
mean how many times have you seen a
person with a beer in their hand smoking
a cigarette saying they don't do drugs
it is so [ __ ] stupid but it's it's so
common there is
this very very very common aspect of
being a person which is these desire to
change your mental state and we've done
it throughout history with various
substances but there's so much stigma
attached to it and one of the things
I've been doing lately on stage I'll ask
people how many people get pissed tested
at work
it's [ __ ] stunning it's stunning it's
like more than 10% of the audience will
raise the hand like 1 out of 10 people
gets there their body tested to make
sure that while they're not working
there they're not putting anything in
their body that's prohibited which is
such a horrible invasion of privacy they
you know that became so popular that in
the 80s during one presidential election
all the candidates voluntarily had their
urine tested to prove that they were
sober I mean this is like truly
considered a virtue and it's immensely
invasive I say this is someone who's
analyzed my own urine in a laboratory
before and it's like a strange portal
into your own life that you're showing
to a stranger everything that you've
consumed is then apparent there yeah and
it's incredibly it's a huge invasion of
privacy that we've just decided is
acceptable and you have to be very
careful about these things yeah no I
agree it's and of course the synthetic
cannabinoid epidemic if you want to call
it that I actually don't want to call it
that because even the idea of a drug
epidemic but the the popularity of
synthetic cannabinoids is largely driven
by the fact that they didn't show up on
these urine tests so initially was in
the military then it was people who are
on parole or probation people who were
living hard lives wanted to get high
couldn't get high this was a way that
they could do it and so they've
incentivized people that just wanted to
smoke weed using completely untested
synthetic cannabinoids instead as a
direct result of these urine tests well
it's also just a complete
misunderstanding it comes to the actual
effects and how long they last you're
not even testing a person's conscious
state you're testing whether or not a
person has altered their state of
consciousness outside of their their
working time you know it's not like you
show up and they could scan your hand
and realize that you're high on
marijuana right
now that's not what they're doing what
they're doing is they're they're testing
you for something that could linger in
your body for weeks after these
psychoactive effects of long since gone
oh yeah or even be the result of passive
exposure there was a great scientific
article that came out a couple of years
ago where they found that just passive
exposure to cannabis smoke contaminates
her hair with THC so that all these
people who had hair tests who actually
had not smoked cannabis but it sounds
like an excuse I was just in the room
someone else is doing it just being in
contact with someone who'd smoked
cannabis could then deposit THC in your
hair and cause you to test positive so
these tests aren't even necessarily
reliable this is the same problem there
is a kind of trend a little while ago if
you saw about this where people would
get their urine tested for different to
quantify the levels of neurotransmitter
metabolites in their urine and this was
supposed to be like a fingerprint of
your mood so they'd quantify the level
of serotonin dopamine GABA whatever
whatever whatever and then they'd say oh
you're a little low on serotonin you're
pretty depressed actually you need to
supplement with some 5-htp or something
like that it's a very reductive way of
thinking about consciousness but the
main issue is that you're not testing in
your brain you're testing your urine and
a lot of these neurotransmitters are bio
synthesized in the periphery so just
because you have these neurotransmitters
in your urine doesn't mean they were
ever in your brain it doesn't say
anything about anything
so it's just it's so juvenile in a way
it says such a it's such a piss-poor way
of maintaining order
checking people's consciousness and
making me what you should do is judge
people based on the productivity if I
have some guy and he shows up for work
and he kicks ass every day I'm like dude
what's your secret you know I get high
before work it's great
I feel good having a good time at work
zip-a-dee-doo-dah Zippity day I'm
putting everything in order and it just
feels good like keep doing what you're
doing that's how it should be we we
should be judged based on whether or not
whatever we're doing is I mean I guess
the real caveat Tibet would be people
that do speed oh yeah I mean you would
get pretty productive for a short period
of time doing speed but I think the
downside of that there's so many people
that are on adderall today right what
are your feelings on that I think that
it's a very interesting issue because
it's amazing when you look at the
history of all these things how these
issues repeat themselves over and over
and over again so it was a problem in
the 50s and it's a problem in the 60s
and it's a problem in the 70s now it's a
problem now it's always a problem that
we're treating as if it were a new thing
but people have been using and fetta
mean type stimulants for the better part
of a hundred years and people will now
the kind of popular thing to say is you
know didn't you know adderall is one
carbon atom away from meth but here's
the flipside meth is one carbon away
from adderall so this whole idea that
meth again back to pharmacological
determinism that meth is a drug that
turns you into a toothless insane
white-trash guy who's stabbing the walls
of the cleaver looking for people that
are hiding and whispering secret
messages or something like that like
this is just a stereotype that we have
created of course there are people like
that but the reality is that these
stimulants have an ambiguous potential
for all sorts of things
some people use low doses of
methamphetamine in fact methamphetamine
is scheduled to because to this day it
can be and is prescribed as a treatment
for ADHD in addition to amphetamine
which is adderall what do they call it
when they prescribe it des auxin is the
brand name for methamphetamines and
adderall is the brand
for amphetamines and their vet and I
tried both drugs both amphetamine and
methamphetamine and they're very very
similar drugs and that's not to say that
either are good or bad it's just a
factual statement that if in a
double-blind placebo-controlled or not
even placebo control just a double-blind
trial I don't think that I could it
could GHD it could also help obese
patients lose weight yeah did you know
that um there's a lot of people that
think Trump is on diet pills oh yeah
yeah on a diet appropiate yeah right
yeah and that he used to be on one of
the one of the elements of Finn Finn
Fenn Fenn Fenn Fenn Fenn flare I mean
maybe yeah yeah phentermine well there
was a some journalists that even talked
about the dwight we saved this we have
it on a folder now what do you say Jamie
I've been hit up messages about that
journalist oh he might be calm catches
their sketchy or something yeah but even
if he were on diethyl propane or then
Fleur Amin or phentermine or fen
metazine or any of these substances yeah
so what well the question is is his
judgment compromised because he's hopped
up on speed his judgment seems
compromised
regardless but is that why no probably
no you know I uh but it could be why he
gets so much [ __ ] done I mean remember
when during the your your you just don't
want to compliment I mean I understand
that no no that's not why it's again
it's this idea there's a certain
exculpatory value the drugs have people
make the same arguments about Hitler
like Hitler he was just high on speed
that explains it the Nazis they were
just high on speed that explains it but
what value does it really have the same
thing with Anthony Bourdain let's say oh
no drugs were found in his system
postmortem
so what what if they had been then what
well the idea is that he might have been
experiencing a [ __ ] up state of mind
because of some drug that made him make
a poor choice and take his own life but
you wouldn't know you wouldn't know why
he did it is that what you're saying it
wouldn't explain anything really because
you still wouldn't know his internal
state it would just be you're projecting
an assumption so what if there were a
small amount of heroin in his blood at
the time of his death then you would
assume that he had relapsed was so
ashamed of his relapse that he then
decided to kill himself by
the reality is we can't make those sorts
of assessments we don't know other
people's internal states we don't even
know what these things do to other
people we don't but we do know that some
things like abilify and some other SSRIs
and even some anti-anxiety medication
have been strongly linked to suicidal
thoughts and in in fact there are
actually listed as some side effects for
a lot of these drugs yes don't you think
that I mean I know correlation does not
equal causation but don't you think that
that's worth considering and it's
something to be discussed it's worth
considering but I would be careful about
assigning too much value to it which is
what people tend to do same thing with
Columbine and they'll say oh he was on
this without antidepressant that's why
is it why does it really explain it
because there's a hell of a lot of
people to take those same drugs and
don't kill all of their classmates right
right for sure for sure but it also
could be a factor and this is not
something I think we should avoid
considering I think it should be
discussed
yes I agree with you you know but I
think we were trying to look at things
binary right we're looking at things in
terms of like on or off black or white 1
or 0 and I just don't think drugs work
that way no and I think you agree yeah
the speed thing is curious to me because
one of the side effects of these drugs
is impulsive irrational behavior and a
extreme confidence in oneself oh yeah
this is this is right this is what we
always think of people that are hopped
up on speed people that have coke
confidence you know coke confidence is a
real phenomenon what people do cocaine
they feel very confident about
themselves and they they say ridiculous
[ __ ] to people so the question is is
that really what's happening if they of
I gave coke to you would you start
acting irrationally and feeling
extremely confident yourself or is it
just accentuating a problem that already
exists in the person's personality both
probably yeah a combination of the two
but the other thing is even if he has
been using this stuff for decades he's
probably tolerant to it and it's not I
don't think it would explain his
behavior well I think it's giving him
energy he's been like this for so long
know this I mean this is a long history
of this sort of behavior this was what
the journalist had talked about that he
had been on this stuff for a long
time and that there was a actual duane
reade pharmacy in new york we described
where he got the prescription filled
people were doing the same thing with
his finasteride as well though and I
found that particularly obnoxious
finasteride is falesha so they were
saying oh he's on finasteride and that
explains you know is a fare or that
explains this because it does this or
that to your libido and again it's like
I don't know or not at all or let's give
him some credit for being a human being
with freewill that makes choices on his
own that aren't entirely mediated by
what Pharmaceuticals uses well for an
asteroid also has side effects of
depression and we went over this
yesterday with my friend Ari who was
really depressed at one point in time
and it coincided with his use of
finasteride right yeah I've seen but
it's not very common it does occur but
it's not uncommon right but for the
person that does get those side effects
saying that it's not common doesn't
really offer any comfort no no okay call
wag I'm one of the lucky ones yeah I'm
one of the lucky ones was it jump off a
bridge get my hair to grow back but you
know the reason that I'm so opinionated
about this particular issue is because
you see a time and time again it never
stops you know I don't know if you're
familiar with the Geoffrey McDonald
murder case no I'm super fascinating
he'd probably have read about it and
forgot about it was a big thing and
maybe 1970 but he was this military
doctor who's credentialed the perfect
man did everything right perfect family
everything beautiful and then one night
he goes to sleep and claims that is
right after the Manson murders claims
that these hippies walk into the house
saying kill the pigs acid is groovy kill
the pigs acid is groovy
and then just brutally Massacre his
entire family and out of nowhere out of
nowhere yes and and it's a long and
complicated story but he went to prison
I don't think that he is guilty but
people had to find an explanation for
wine you don't think he's guilty I don't
think he's guilty he had no mode
and there were and the investigation was
botched and so you think someone came
into his house and did that yes he was
accused of yes but but because he had no
motive people had to construct a motive
that could concoct a reason that this
doctor would have murdered his entire
family and so what's a good reason oh
and feta mean he'd been using this
amphetamine containing diet pills so
that explains it all right but it
doesn't
it's a terrible explanation people use
him feta mean all the time without
killing their family so I just want to
be very careful about it you know do
these things play a role in human
behavior of course they do
but do they determine human behavior no
that's a very good point there's a lot
of factors there's just it's messy being
a person is messing it's very
complicated I mean you're a different
person at noon than you are at 7 p.m. of
course yeah I mean
it's just it's so complicated and the
more limitations we put on research and
the more stigma we put on the use of
these things the more murky these waters
are going to be yeah and I think people
don't even appreciate the extent to
which all these drugs have been made
illegal of course everyone's where
cannabis is scheduled on LSD psilocybin
MDMA but the list is long it's hundreds
and hundreds of chemicals and a lot of
these chemicals are chemicals with no
supporters no one's fighting for them
there's a substance called 2cn one of
Sheldon's creations they just threw it
in schedule and no one uses it if you
scour the internet I'd be surprised if
you could find three reports of people
using 2cn totally unheard of but they
just throw it in schedule one because
why the hell not no one's gonna stand up
for it that's the end of 2cn but they
miss a lot of [ __ ] too right like they
miss five methoxy dimethyltryptamine
they missed that no that was made
illegal in 2011 right but yeah for 1970
when everything else got thrown into the
mix they made it illegal
I bought that [ __ ] used to be able to
buy it online yeah so did I yeah I was
crazy you could buy a [ __ ] jug of it
then get the whole city hi yeah bye
it'll online yeah because it was never
popular so how do they make it illegal
how do they how do they do that they
don't need any reason they can simply
say that it has abuse potential and make
it illegal and if no one opposes it then
it becomes illegal that's how this list
has gotten so long you have all these
people fighting for the legality of
cannabis and these other substances that
are known to have therapeutic potential
but these other more obscure substances
that are really only a concern to
scientists who are very seriously
disinclined to break the law for the
sake of their research drug users don't
care about breaking law scientists are
very unlikely because the whole purpose
of science is to publish and you can't
publish if you committed a crime in the
context of your research so scientists
are dramatically limited by the
prohibition of these substances and it's
the obscure ones that end up actually
making a big difference not so much
clinically but in terms of actually
understanding the mechanism of these
substances the structure-activity
relationships the neuropharmacology yeah
the stigma on psychedelic you
and in even studying them has led so
many doctors or scientists researchers
that would be inclined to want to do
research on these particular things they
avoid them because it could be
incredibly damaging to their careers and
it's bureaucratic I mean there was a
group at Columbia that was doing really
fascinating research on the drug
ibogaine and Parkinson's disease and the
I was speaking with the head of the
study and he was saying how obnoxious it
was to have the government common way
his vial of ibogaine every day and
monitor his logs and you know this guy
is a really serious researcher he's not
gonna if you were to get high he's not
gonna get high off this tiny supply of
government mandated or government
sanctioned ibogaine right that was
supplied to him but but they give these
people a really hard time they make them
buy a very expensive safe they do all
this stuff that these are the last
people to abuse the substances it's and
they are the ones that are hurt the most
severely except for of course the people
to go to prison they're the ones that
are hurt the most severely yeah it's a
crazy thing to think that people are
gonna recreationally use IVA gain that's
that's one of the weirder ones oh it's
it's totally bizarre
yeah and and ibogaine is a drug with so
much potential for those people that are
aware of ibogaine it's typically only
discussed as a drug that treats
addiction to opioids which is very very
important especially now but that's the
tip of the iceberg with ibogaine it has
one of the most complex pharmacology of
any drug I've ever studied there's
almost nothing it does not do I mean
it's you know you have the alpha 3 beta
for nicotine ik acetylcholine receptor
which is also the target of wellbutrin
and has a kind of smoking cessation anti
addictive effect then you have really
high affinity relative to the other
receptors for the NMDA receptor so it
has a ketamine type effect and has a
classical psychedelic effect at the
5-htt to a receptor then it's a dopamine
reuptake inhibitor serotonin reuptake
inhibitor it's screws goes on and then
it releases this protein GD n F which is
considered one of the most important
proteins in treatment of Parkinson's
disease it's one of the only things that
is able to cause regrowth of
dopaminergic neurons and people that
have parkinson's so this is like really
fascinating stuff that's just
in schedule 1 scientists can't work with
it is a tragedy it is a tragedy and it's
also so effective I know so many people
that have gone to Mexico and gone to
these clinics and done one ibogaine
session for 24 hours and come out of it
a totally different person come out of
with with a complete new perspective on
even why they were using whatever they
were using in the first place in a way
that they didn't it not only is it
helped eliminate the addictive
properties and the connection that your
body has to those substances but it also
allows you to re-examine why you went
down that road in the first place yeah
oh yeah and there you know there was a
sort of pharmaceutical push to develop
non psychedelic derivatives of ibogaine
that would retain the anti addictive
properties which sounds like a good idea
in theory but so they created this drug
called 18m C and it wasn't psychedelic
but then it also lacked some of these
neurotrophins ive ibogaine but really
the bottom line is that we shouldn't
deny the fact that the psychedelic
activity of these substances is
therapeutic psychotherapeutic in and of
itself you know I had a friend who was
severely severely addicted to heroin and
he traveled to the Netherlands to take
ibogaine and you know took the drug was
going into the experience and started
feeling this intense craving for heroin
and it started looking through his bags
to see if he'd somehow put a little had
forgotten about a little bit of heroin
that could just get him through the day
and then he he goes into his bag and and
then finds a small bag of heroin and
snorts it and then is like I traveled
all the way to the Netherlands to do
this this was I'm a failure I'm
relapsing after all this money all this
work I have no self-control I'm a
terrible terrible person why can't I
just stop and then realize that the
whole thing was a hallucination there
was no heroin he'd hallucinate Adhir own
relapse whoa
Wow
what was your experience with ibogaine
I've never taken high doses the most
I've ever taken is 50 milligrams of
listen effective dose it really depends
there's a sort of move toward micro
dosing ibogaine because it actually does
have a cardiotoxic effect especially at
higher doses so people are looking into
ways of reducing that cardio toxicity by
using it at lower doses for longer
periods of time again this is something
that has to do with prohibition because
in a this prohibition market if you are
addicted to heroin you go to Mexico or
you go to Canada and you go to an
ibogaine clinic you need to get as much
bang for your buck as quickly as
possible you're not going to stay there
for two months of treatment because most
people have lives and can't afford to do
that so what do you do they give you
what is called a flood dose it's a
massive dose often a multi gram dose of
ibogaine because it's just like a
sledgehammer that knocks you down and
allows you to get out of it but is that
the best way that's the fastest way
that's the most appetizing way for
someone that had to travel to do it but
is it the best probably not because we
know that it high doses it has this
potential to induce cardiac arrhythmias
and that can kill and has killed so
people are yet now looking at lower
doses over longer periods of time which
would be ideal if it were legal in the
United States I believe mm-hmm yeah
that's it's a really interesting one to
me it's a it's a really interesting one
because it's got such a long history of
use and so many people have had these
very good experiences with getting off
of addictive drugs from it oh yeah and
it's so relatively unknown as well it's
it's something that you know talk to
someone like you and of course you know
about it but I mean I bet if we walk
down the street and asked a hundred
people I'd be shocked if one of them
knew about it yeah and you know Terence
Mckenna would sometimes talk about
psilocybin as an invention of mushrooms
or as technology or as being synthetic
and I don't really agree with that idea
but an invention of mushrooms or you
would sort of say like this is as
synthetic as a coca-cola bottle this is
like alien
technology that's how you would describe
psilocybin but in my opinion in its you
know it's a pretty simple derivative of
tryptophan you just decarboxylate
methylate the nitrogen twice and then
had this phosphate ester but but
ibogaine that's a crazy molecule that's
like a three-dimensional thing that no
medicinal chemist would have ever
discovered that if there's you know not
to sound mystical but that strikes me as
some sort of plant technology I mean
it's an amazingly complicated structure
it's so complicated that it's almost
impossible to synthesize in fact it
can't be synthesized commercially all
the ibogaine that people use has to be
extracted from plants because that's the
only way to get it Wow I first found out
about it when when Hunter s Thompson
accused Edie muskie of being on it
during the presidential race of was at
1970 or whatever it was that was a
hilarious moment and a lot of people I
think were introduced to what ibogaine
was by that when he said a Brazilian
witch doctor had been flown in it
doesn't even grow in Brazil yeah it
doesn't even make sense well it's also
it was hilarious when he was on the Dick
Cavett show and they asked him about
spreading those rumors and he's like
well there was a rumor that he was doing
this ibogaine and I know because I
started the rumor ha ha ha I just
reported factually there was a rumor
yeah it's there's there's a lot of these
drugs that get put into various
categories and ibogaine is one of the
very few that really isn't in any
category in terms of like modern culture
like the way we discuss and consider
these things oh because it's very
different structurally and Formica
logically but that Hunter has Thompson
story is really interesting because it's
obviously a very charming funny story
and I'd have to know exactly when it
happened relative to the scheduling of
ibogaine but that might be an example of
how what's a you know frivolous joke
that most people enjoy told in the wrong
climate can result in the loss of a
chemical that could be good that could
save tens of thousands of lives and
could be a treatment for part
since disease hmm you know this is the
responsibility that journalists have
it's more responsibility than I think
they'd like to have often but that's the
truth you make a joke about ibogaine
next thing you know it's in schedule one
maybe he made the joke afterwards but if
he didn't you have to wonder because
that was one of the first major mentions
of ibogaine in the popular press and the
same is true of you know there was a
Rolling Stone scare article that came
out a while ago and it's same deal this
drug to ct7 and they do a whole story oh
this teenager he took too much and this
too ct7 it can kill you with just a you
know a little pile of powder or whatever
and and then the drug is made schedule
one shelgon worked on psychedelics
alexander shulgin great medicinal
chemists who spent his entire life
studying psychedelics considered this
one of the six greatest creations of his
entire career squashed by a single
stupid story in Rolling Stone
that's how easily it happens now was the
story stupid I mean did it have any
basis in fact an editor at rolling stone
told me that there were factual errors
in it and there's something weird about
it but yes people did die because yes
people die from using drugs occasionally
to deny that would be to lie but that
doesn't mean that they don't have
therapeutic activity and it doesn't mean
that they should be illegal one of the
ones that disturbs me the most is
fentanyl fentanyl just I don't even
understand why anybody would want to
make that it seems to me that we have no
any of opiates as it is why make one
that's a thousand times stronger than
heroin yeah I've known for fentanyl
chemists including the one that
introduced fentanyl to the United States
initially he died recently did he die
from it no died of all day it just
killed so many people yeah Tom Petty
David Boies it was Bowie one I'm not
sure prints yeah I mean there's quite a
few great people that we've lost to this
stuff yeah it's really it's unfortunate
but again fentanyl is not the problem
the problem people taking problems
people taking it and the problem is lack
of access to say for opioids and lack of
education surrounding fentanyl because
it doesn't even really have desirable
properties you know one thing that
people always talk about the potent
the offense and one thing that they
don't often talk about is the duration
it's a very very short duration opioid
which necessitates compulsive constant
Rideau Singh if you're addicted to
fentanyl unless you're doing a
transdermal patch or something like that
you typically can't make it through a
single night without having to reduce
because the duration is so short that's
why it's always done in these prolonged
release formulations like a lollipop
that you sock or a patch
but anyway it's yet it's not a drug
that's well suited to street use it's to
the therapeutic index is to narrow its
duration is to short it has a medical
purpose that it works very well for it
shouldn't be used as a heroin
replacement but the economic reality is
that you have to make heroin from opium
opium ask that come from a place where
poppies are grown that's a whole process
whereas fentanyl can be made by one guy
somewhere and the profit margin on the
fentanyl is so much greater that there's
an enormous economic incentive and the
first chemist this guy that was sort of
a friend of mine that died to do it
considered it a good thing to do
that's the complexity that you have to
recognize it's so easy to say that all
these people are so bad but often you
don't know what's gonna happen until it
happens his idea was that one of the
major burdens of being addicted to
heroin is that you can't afford it it's
really expensive so by substituting this
relatively inexpensive material the
price of heroin would go down this
financial burden associated with opioid
addiction would be reduced it would
actually improve the quality of life of
the users and it could even be a more
pure potentially safer material if you
look at certain literature of course
that's not what happened and many people
died and he went to prison as a result
of it did he really yes why did he go to
prison for it because people died and it
was traced back to him Wow yeah so he
wasn't doing this in any sanctioned know
he was in clandestine chemist his name
was George Marquardt weird guy yeah I
guess yeah but anyway you know you just
don't know you don't know what's going
to happen until it happens you know of
course the legendary story that heroin
was introduced by Bayer as an
addictive alternative to morphine they
probably did think that was the case at
the beginning but history has shown that
that is not the case that's one of the
problems with introducing any drug to a
large population you simply don't know
it's and it's also one of the things
that I find most interesting in and
perhaps a silver lining in this whole
synthetic cannabinoid narrative that's
been playing out over the last decade is
you could say oh it's terrible people
should just smoke cannabis but we're
learning so much about what cannabinoid
receptor agonists can do that we would
have never learned if it weren't for the
widespread use of synthetic cannabinoids
I mean just for instance that it is
possible for high potencies cannabinoid
receptor agonists to kill you that's a
big one we didn't know that until
recently that they can be addictive we
didn't know that what are they using
what is it it's so it's an impressively
diverse array of chemicals you know it
started out with a drug called CP 55 940
then it was CP they call it cannabis I
Clos hexanol now and then J WH 18 j wh
73 j wh 210 on and on and on and on and
then it just branched like a giant
cannabinoid fractal in every imaginal
imaginable direction and in a lot of
these compounds you know they were
patented by various pharmaceutical
companies like Pfizer for therapeutic
purposes again this wasn't some
malevolent chemists whose cackling and
saying ha ha ha I figured out the most
addictive thing possible they were just
looking to see what's legal what looks
pretty potent and reasonably safe okay
we'll make that we'll sell it and and
I've spoken with the chemists actually
we're behind a lot of these operations
again not bad guys necessarily they they
you know typically people don't want to
hurt other people you know genuine
villainous people are pretty rare in my
experience most people believe that what
they're doing has a justification that
is good and again with the synthetic
cannabinoid ideas one is that although
you won't hear this in the popular press
and it's rarely said they can be very
enjoyable and it would be dishonest to
say otherwise
some of them are very euphoric and
compared favorably to cannabis and in
certain measures might even be superior
that as a
they're safer it just means that there's
something very desirable about them and
if you deny that then you neglect to
understand why people use them in the
first place which is that they make you
feel good so that's part of it but then
the other thing is that urine testing
people wanting to be able to get high
without breaking the law low cost I mean
there's a lot of motivations for doing
this and as it played out people died
people became addicted and random things
that no one would have ever expected
occurred we learned
here's another silver lining I'm sure
you're familiar with cannabis
hyperemesis syndrome no not you know
this this bizarre pattern that certain
people that smoke all day every day it
started showing up in the medical
literature about a decade ago people
smoked all day every day and they start
getting very very nauseous and start
vomiting and the only thing that can
relieve the vomiting is a hot shower huh
so really weird so all these people are
showing up in emergency rooms when they
like run out of hot water saying like I
need some kind of I need some help or
something like I don't know what's going
on the condition resolves itself very
rapidly as soon as you stop smoking
cannabis so it's not hard to treat you
just can't smoke weed anymore but no one
knew what caused it and why it was
happening now after thousands of years
of human cannabis interaction why now
for the first time in history and the
answer is that people are smoking more
weed now than ever before
you know the levels of THC ingestion
with dabbing and high potency strains
are just higher for some people it's
much higher than has ever been in the
past but but then the question is what
is causing it is it the cannabis itself
is it a fertilizer is it a pesticide
what is responsible for this and it
wasn't until people with using synthetic
cannabinoids began to experience the
same constellation of symptoms that they
realized that this is an intrinsic
property of certain cannabinoid receptor
agonists so that's something that you
can learn from all of this that it
wasn't pesticides and it wasn't some
kind of fungus or something like that
growing on the plant but this is
something that happens from prolonged
high dose use of cannabinoids and
there's all sorts of other lessons that
can be learned is that an issue with
cannabis use pesticides have you ever
heard of people having real
most historically it was certainly you
know paraquat pot did you ever you know
what's not paraquat was uh you know in
one of many misguided attempts to
prevent people from using drugs they
started spraying all the cannabis it was
grown in mexico with this ultra toxic
herbicide called paraquat and this is a
drug that induces parkinson's disease
when you're exposed to it like really
seriously nasty stuff no joke and so the
idea was if we poison all the cannabis
and create this widespread fear that
whatever you're smoking might contain
paraquat maybe people will use it less
and luckily paraquat is doesn't have a
lot of thermo Stability it's sort of
denatured by the heat of smoking so it's
argued that people were not actually
exposed to it who smoked it but still
this is a horrendous thing for the
government to have done they did the
same thing during alcohol prohibition by
the way that would poison alcohol I mean
that's the extent they'll poison people
to prevent them from getting high but
that's a reality but but now in turn you
know it there's obviously a move toward
organic gardening people using you know
neem oil and things like that so I
wouldn't know oh and there was the other
was actually a big controversy in
Colorado with a pesticide called Mike
clove butanol I believe that was used
and potentially could release cyanide
when smoked so yeah yeah well I would
worry about that with large-scale
production things become commercially
viable the point where someone like r.j.
Reynolds gets into the mix and starts
growing enormous marijuana plantations
oh yeah I mean it's a concern with all
the food that we eat as well of course
yeah what is interesting to you now like
is there anything that's coming up or
some new thing that people are might not
be aware of that might be fascinating to
you yeah I mean I'm I'm I'm interested
in everything you know I love the
history I love you know I did a piece in
this last season of my TV show where I
trace the history of psychedelic totem
of five Meo DMT containing toad venom
because people
this idea that all psychedelics have
been used for thousands of years that
every psychedelic has an ancient history
but when you look at the history of five
Meo DMT there is no evidence really no
convincing evidence that I'm aware of
maybe you can point to it you know
ceramic toad is that evidence that
people smoked toad venom not in my
opinion it might be some indication that
maybe they did but it's certainly not
hard evidence even if there were this
guy sitting on his back smoking a pipe
it wouldn't be hard evidence mmm but
anyway so there isn't convincing
evidence as far as I'm concerned of
ancient toad venom use so then the
question is when did it start who was
the first person to do this and I I love
these little historical investigations
to get to the bottom who is the first
person to synthesize this drug what were
their intentions who is the first person
to smoke toad venom and why in the toad
venom is a weird one - because this is
bizarre misconception that you lick the
toads right
which again journalistically produced
maybe was inspired by cartoons as well
to some extent but I yes so the way you
do it is you have to get the toad to
excrete whatever this is and you put it
on glass and then you dry it out is that
the idea that's the idea yes and then
you scrape it off with a razor blade and
then smoke it that's it and does it come
is it a pure form of five amino DMT no
and there's actually very little
chemical analysis that's been done in
the 21st century I analyzed a sample
that I collected when I was in Sonora
and it contained in addition to five Meo
DMT it contains some interesting
serotonin derivatives including
serotonin Oh sulfate and nobody knows
how these different tryptamine
components as well as these steroidal
lactones that are sometimes called Bufo
tox and contribute to the experience if
I had to guess probably not that much
but maybe there's a little bit of that
sort of entourage effect that you get
with almost any plant that has a variety
of different alkaloids that might
inhibit certain enzymes or do this or
that but it's about 15% according to the
older literature the analysis that I did
wasn't quantitative so I don't know
exactly what the concentration was but
it's somewhere in that region and I'm
sure it depends on whether the toad has
been milked previously in all these
other variables does the experience
mirror taking synthetic 5mm
dmt I haven't tried I've tried synthetic
five Meo DMT a couple times have tried
bufo alvarius venom once at a low dose
once at a high dose they were all
different but then everything is
different mushrooms are different every
time I take them you know it's really
hard once you start explaining a
different experience based on the
composition of the material because how
do you assign it to the dose or the
minut number of different tryptamines
that are also present it's really hard
to say but you know I think that there
is a strong argument to be made for
using the synthetic as opposed to the
toad drive material simply because you
don't have to harm or hurt not that it
necessarily does harm toads but you
don't even have to risk it right right
and it's easy to synthesize yeah I'm
sure toads aren't into getting rubbed on
windshields yeah seems like a annoying
day for a toad yeah yeah they want to
eat insects yeah whatever the [ __ ] they
do one of the more interesting stories
out of the last decade or so was this
story that I read about these scholars
in Jerusalem that were connecting the
story of Moses in the burning bush to
the acacia bush and the Keysha tree
which is rich in DMT and they believed
that you know when you're talking about
a story that was told through oral
traditions for who knows how many years
and then written down in ancient Hebrew
and then transcribed and you know and
translated to Greek and Latin and all
these day there's a lot lost in the mix
and they believed that what that story
might have been about of Moses coming
down from Mount Sinai with the the
tablets and having the experience with
meeting God and the burning bush that
what this is in fact was a
dimethyltryptamine experience maybe yeah
it's a big maybe it's a big maybe I can
say that if you go to the south of
Mexico and Chiapas there's a tree that
grows there is a weed called mimosa
hostilius maybe you're familiar with it
and this is so abundant that it's used
to make fence posts all the fences on
the side of the road are made of mosul
hostel as its uses firewood to cook
meals the air smells like DMT because
people are using it as fuel all over the
place
not a single person that I spoke with
was aware that it was psychoactive these
are people that are burning it all the
time do they get high from it is there
like if you were in a tent or something
like that you were doing a hotbox sort
of scenario would you get high from it
no I saw no would you it may be it's
about 2% DMT so you'd probably have to
get so sick from big coughing and yeah
it would be a very I mean even just
smoking pure crystal DMT can be very
difficult for some people so my guess
not to be like a wet blanket but my
guess is not really and that's a very
strong source as strong as maybe there's
a some acacia is stronger but that's
certainly comparable and that's
something people are using to cook food
all the time they're not aware that it's
psychoactive so was there a way or is
there a way for a person living
thousands of years ago to somehow or
another extract DMT from something like
the acacia tree that's a actually spent
some time thinking about that a while
ago it would be
first of all depends on how you define
extraction if it were to in like an
ayahuasca sends like a tea of course yes
but then they would need some sort of
enzyme inhibitor to create the ayahuasca
if it were to create an isolated
smokeable form again you know you could
just do like an aqueous infusion and
then dry that out and maybe smoke that
but in terms of like a real extraction
that would produce crystals of DMT I
don't know what the nonpolar solvent
they would be using to extract the
freebase would be like butter or
something and then how would you get rid
of the butter so what is the process
like if you're gonna take a tree that's
rich in DMT and extract DMT from it what
what do you have to use have you ever
done it before no I've never done it oh
okay well it's it's a very generalizable
and simple process that applies to
almost everything in chemistry it's you
know sometimes it's called an acid base
extraction most people that are in the
DMT community go something they call
straight to base and you know the idea
is that the sidechain of the DMT
molecule contains a basic nitrogen that
if it's protonated in an acidic solution
then it's water soluble and if it's
deprotonated then it's only soluble in a
non-polar solvent so what you do is you
just deprotonate the nitrogen with a
base potassium hydroxide or sodium
hydroxide typically and then treat that
aqueous basic solution with a non-polar
solvent like naphtha and isolate the
naphtha dry it out and you have your
material and that applies to everything
that's not a DMT specific process but
that's what people do hmm everything
with the basic nitrogen now what's the
earliest history of extraction do we
well you know the first wave of DMT use
in the United States was all synthetic
in fact DMT was discovered synthetically
before it was ever found in nature the
same is true of five Meo DM how'd they
do that
there was a Canadian chemist named
Richard Hellmuth Manske who I believe is
looking at different alkaloids in
strawberry plants and he was
synthesizing references for these
potential strawberry alkaloids and made
DMT so he didn't know what he had made
other than a potential natural product
found in strong
and and then it wasn't until
saara much later conducted self
experiments with injected DMT that
people became fully aware of its psycho
activity and then people started finding
it in plants I mean the the nineteen
fifties were like I've and early sixties
were of course a fascinating time in
psychedelic research because you have
these convergences of these amazing
ideas first you have the discovery of
serotonin which is like you know we take
this for granted now it's in television
commercials but this is of course
something that no one knew about and
suddenly they're finding this in all
kinds of different animals initially it
was in the the salivary glands of squid
and in different animals than they're
finding it in the human intestine then
they're also finding that all of these
plants that people worshipped in various
indigenous societies also contain
serotonin like molecules and they
discover LSD and find that that's maybe
the most potent known pharmacological
agent at that time and it binds to
serotonin receptors it activates a
serotonin type response in isolated
tissue so there's like this weird triple
convergence of information super potent
amazing compound LSD is discovered
serotonin is discovered in all these
different organisms and there's a
pharmacological convergence between the
two of them and then you have all these
people worshipping serotonin like
molecules so there was you know a lot of
enthusiasm at that time to figure all
this out so in terms of history so we're
talking about like somewhere in the
1950s they started extracting DMT the
use of it orally dates back far longer
than that because of use of mao
inhibitors and creating ayahuasca but in
terms of the first extraction we can
kind of iceland's yeah smoke yeah it
might have been even later it might have
been in the 80s okay so the idea that
people thousands of years ago
we're able to do something along those
lines is probably probably not accurate
because because they're talking about a
burning bush that's why it's appealing
to people right
the idea of Moses do you do you think
that maybe the understanding of
synthesis from the you know synthesizing
this from these scholars maybe they
don't have enough of an understanding of
chemistry well what would be really
interesting is to do an experiment to
see what were the materials that were
available how would this have been done
would you have to use butter as your
nonpolar solvent how well would that
work what would your butter preparation
be done where you put it would you take
it rectally then is that how it would
work I mean you have to kind of load
your base have been well I think they
were talking about it being something
from I mean burning right a burning bush
maybe it's just one of those things that
sort of gets conflated right because you
have people today that are very aware
that people smoked DMT and have these
incredibly Tent intense religious
psychedelic experiences and then maybe
they looked at the acacia bush and said
oh the acacia bush is rich in DMT that's
probably where the Moses story came from
right well what's really interesting is
you know DMT has never been found in the
human brain even though Rick Strassman
says that it has been so a lot of people
are constantly assigning altered states
of consciousness to DMT but we can have
these states without DMT I mean maybe
it's never been found in the human brain
but also there's ethical and
experimental issues with sampling fluid
from a living humans brain right but it
has they have found it in living rats
okay this is fairly recently yes this is
a con Wood Research Foundation that's
their their attempt is to try to prove
that the pineal gland is a source for
DMT we know that DMT exists in the human
body we know that the liver produces it
and we know that the lungs produce it
yeah we're not totally aware of whether
or not there's anecdotal evidence that
points to the pineal gland based on the
rat idea and based on the presence of
certain enzymes that could be
responsible for it but even if it is
even if it is then what there's still a
whole question of how is it released how
is it distributed what receptors does it
activate and is it even necessary as an
explanation for altered states of
consciousness because there
other things in the brain other than DMT
DMT has never even been found in the
room but there are other things you know
you have endogenous proteins that bind
to the Kappa opioid receptor the same
receptor that is responsible for the
effect of Salvia things like that they
agree are responsible I mean even carbon
dioxide itself can induce a pretty
strong altered state of consciousness
right which is why people like those
psychedelic breathing exercises yeah
they're sort of is it like hypoxic is
that what it is what are they doing when
they they have those the what is it
called there's a type of breathing
exercise that induces psychedelic states
holotropic College rhetoric yeah
and that is the idea behind that right
it increases the amount of carbon
dioxide in your blood I haven't seen a
mechanistic explanation hmm yeah I think
that was but it would yeah it would make
sense in an early LSD psychotherapy one
of the things that they would do before
giving someone LSD is it give them
something called carbage in' which was a
gas that contained carbon dioxide and
they would look at their response to the
carbon dioxide inhalation and if it
induced a panic response they would say
maybe you're not psychologically ready
for this LSD experience so that was
you're talking about a test I mean that
was a very primitive early test that was
used by psychiatrists to see if people
were had the psychological fortitude to
withstand the experience that's
fascinating so tell me more about
whatever is in the brain that mirrors
the effects of salvia it's a protein I
can't remember off the top of my head
what it it's if you look up endogenous
ligand for cap opioid receptor it will
come up David Nicholls recently wrote a
paper that actually goes into alternate
mechanisms of how the DMT type
near-death experience could be produced
by non DMT compounds but I mean you know
there was a lot of work also on
endogenous NMDA receptor antagonists
there was a a protein that was called
alpha endo psycho sin or angel Dustin
named after angel dust but the main
researcher died in a car accident like
right as he was making some kind of
breakthrough breakthrough supposedly mmm
but cue spooky music yeah but you know
there's all this has been a
long-standing question in psychiatry is
you know what causes psychosis
what causes altered states of
consciousness is there an endogenous
psychedelic that was like one of the
major motivations for a lot of this
research in the 60s finding the
endogenous psychology that is
responsible for schizophrenia now it
doesn't seem to be the case but it's
still a question that comes up
what if dopamine is methylated in a
certain way to create diamond thoughts
even ethylamine or what about this what
about that I mean Sheldon was very
interested in it about the metabolic
production of various psychedelics that
account for altered states of
consciousness it just hasn't been
supported by evidence in a very strong
way even though people really find the
idea compelling and there was also that
v of Mayo DMT and schizophrenic people
see Aaron that's also the thing right
and the we know that the body does
produce five Meo DMT we just don't know
where yet because again it's like what I
was saying earlier about the the
depression tests where you look at your
urine so you find five Meo DMT in your
urine and your first assumption might be
okay there's five Emil DMT in my body it
was in my brain but you don't know that
right it could have been biosynthesized
in your intestine and it could have been
excreted without ever entering your
brain right and this is the whole idea
of mono amine oxidase right the idea
that when we're eating things that are
rich in DMT monoamine oxidase is
breaking it down the gut yeah so even if
you're consuming something so if
something is so how do they know that
this this salvia like substance exists
in the mind or in the brain rather
because this this peptide or protein has
been isolated do you find the name of it
oh okay how I caught four of those words
you said so we know there's a host of
different psychoactive substance that
are absolutely produced by the body and
in in in the MA in the brain and that
there's different ways that human beings
have been able to achieve psychedelic
states
side of consuming drugs have you done
that I've done lucid dreaming things
I've done Kundalini Yoga Kundalini one
is the one I'm most interested in
because I have someone who's a friend of
mine that got really into it and he was
saying that he can achieve very DMT like
states you know there's a really
interesting aspect of all this that
isn't often discussed which is the
ability to have these states and still
interact with your environment because
of course there's something very
physically taxing about Breath of Fire
or these Kundalini breathing techniques
if you induce an altered state of
consciousness and you need to be focused
and you need to be in a specific place
sitting down whereas psychedelics have
this amazing ability to allow you to
have that experience but walk around hmm
and I think that's not to be
underestimated the walking around
because then you can really re-examine
your environment that's a big part of it
for me a big part of the psychedelic
experience is seeing what is New York
like what do I like or not like about
New York what do I like or not like
about my apartment because it matters
things matter this is your environment
do you want you surrounded by clutter
that you don't like if you don't get rid
of it right these are the sorts of
thoughts you have and this is my other
issue with going to the Peruvian Amazon
to have a psychedelic experience because
if you do it in this place that is
superficially inappropriate like your
apartment I think it has the most
applicability to your own existence in
terms of the music you listen to your
friends your environment your life
you're confronted by the books that you
read the photos of the people that you
know all the things that matter to you
not a jungle although jungles are very
beautiful and visually stimulating and
I'm sure then are I know an amazing
place to use psychedelics I think that
we underestimate the value of these
things have when integrated into a more
normal type of experience and that's
something you can't do as easily with
Kundalini right right that makes sense
so when you're using psychedelics you
will use them and walk around New York
City yes what is that like I often feel
a lot of love for Barilla yeah which is
you know because I think that we also
tend to get into these very angry
Subway's annoying the guys taking up too
much room I have to stand it's taking
forever it smells weird whatever
everyone is looking at their phones all
the time which is a little bit dark and
then you know if you're on a low dose of
a psychedelic or even a higher one
sometimes I look at everyone on their
phones and I'll just feel compassion and
love and think like what a strange
situation we've all gotten ourselves
into I love all these people and it's
like I don't know what to say about it
but I understand it completely and I
don't know where we're going from here
and you suddenly feel connected to
something that's very real which is
people in the subway not looking at each
other anymore
yeah I mean this is in my own life
something that has changed dramatically
when I moved to New York no one looked
at phones now people only look at phones
everyone is looking at phones the entire
time they're on the subway this is it
total change in human behavior and you
really start thinking about things like
that and it matters because it's not in
the Amazon it's your life and these are
the things the choices that you make are
you gonna be a person that looks at
their phone all the time as well
yeah it's fascinating how quickly that
took hold yeah if you look at human
history when the iPhone is ten years old
I know and that's really when it started
so ten years ago people and even then in
the beginning of the iPhone they were
[ __ ] useless right you'd get online
it was just really slow and terrible and
so most the time you just text message
it but now with all the apps and social
media and constant constant updates of
information and new things and new
events new trends it's just it's always
calling you I better check make sure
anything's - we've been on this podcast
for two hours let me see what's going on
oh look at that all these massive you
did it to me actually I have this this
vivid memory of standing at your front
door and you selling Twitter to me
saying like oh you've got it you've got
to use Twitter it's amazing people send
all send you all these articles and it's
so useful you learn so much it's really
amazing said it only had one tweet at
that time and now it's like twenty-five
hundred tweets later and hundreds of
hours of my life I'll never come sorry I
got ya I got ya it is that way still for
me in many ways I learn a lot about
what's going on in the world in terms I
follow a lot of science tweets
Twitter counts and a lot of really
interesting people that post interesting
stuff but you gotta know how to abandon
a tweet several words in like this is
[ __ ] I'm not reading that no I'm not
reading that Oh what can they do now it
reads are too long this is crazy no it's
not even that it's just knowing that
it's gonna be horseshit this is gonna be
just either gossip or nonsense or not
interesting but there's still a [ __ ] ton
of really useful information that you
can get out of Twitter on a daily basis
there's always something new that's
coming out and I try to retweet those
things as much as possible when I see
something that someone sends me and then
that becomes people know hey if you send
Joe something really cool and he reads
it if I get a chance to read it I'll
retweet it and people get a kick out of
that so they'll send me more cool stuff
and so then it sort of it's it sort of
becomes a like a little ecosystem almost
for disseminating interesting ideas yeah
let's also [ __ ] - there's a lot of
[ __ ] in there a lot of a lot of
arguing which I don't do I just don't
argue I think it's a very ineffective
way to communicate with people with you
know going back and forth with stuff
like that online it just doesn't work
well it's and it becomes I think more
like idea sport with a lot of folks like
they're just trying to win these little
battles and find the witty or nasty
thing to say and it's just it's not
productive it's not healthy
I don't like it well they're doing the
same thing the journalists do which is
that you get more attention for doing
the wrong thing than you do for saying
the right thing so and we all know that
feeling where someone says something
about you that's unfair and wrong and
you want to say hey wait a second how's
that that is totally incorrect I'm gonna
set the record straight
yeah and that's what gets the engagement
not the kind thoughtful considerate
thing that somebody says yes yes I would
love to accentuate the trend of kindness
I really think that that is one thing if
there's any one trend and to lean
towards kindness to just just
be nicer to people and if we could all
sort of agree that this is a virtue
worth pursuing
I think we could change the way human
beings interact with each other these
shifts like the shift of looking at your
phone if we could figure out a shift and
one of the more disturbing things to me
that comes from the left which I've
always associated myself being a
left-leaning person that there's a lot
of meanness coming from the left now and
so a lot of lot of by any means
necessary a lot of feeling the need to
squash people and humiliate people and
insult people because they don't agree
with what you believe and that this this
is a I think this is a terrible path to
go down because then it sort of
justifies people who think the opposite
of that to be mean to you so now no
one's getting anything done because this
sides being insulting and that sides
being insulting and people are getting
kicked out of restaurants and people are
protesting in front of people's houses
because they disagree with things and
this is a lot of cruelty a lot of like
meanness and cruelty which is the enemy
of discourse as soon as that stuff gets
thrown about and soon as it becomes a
war an idea war or an idea sport people
are just trying to win and they're
trying to get back at you for what you
said and you get back at them for that
and it becomes this terrible stall out
situation yeah we've all bought into a
game and it's a bad game to play it's
the worst possible game and it's very
transparent I mean you look at what
shows up on the first page of Twitter
and it's things that are perfectly
designed to generate opinions so the
teacher says that now classrooms will be
equipped with a bucket of stones to
throw at a school shooter and what do
you feel oh that's stupid or hey that's
actually kind of a good idea it's better
than nothing and everyone's engaging
with it and you're buying into it you're
supporting it and you're promoting it
you're making it bigger by paying
attention to it I mean there's an
amazing book that I recommend anyone
listening to this read called amusing
ourselves to death by Neil postman which
he wrote in 1985 before computers before
social media before any of this he
predicts all of it perfectly without
even knowing the faintest hint of what
was going to happen and you know his
solution if there is one is you know
partially to disengage from all of this
but to try to appreciate long nuanced
careful things which is very hard to
achieve on Twitter or television or most
places we can try our best well I think
that's one of the reasons why podcasts
like especially ones like this that are
these long-form conversations are
becoming popular because people are
hungry for actual communication they're
hungry for people that are just even if
we disagree on things I want to know why
you think the way you think and I want
to hear it all I want to hear all of
your reasoning I want to hear the
thought process that led you to that I
want to hear that and I want to be able
to talk to you about how I think and why
I think the way I think and maybe we can
come to some middle ground or at least
understand each other and go oh I see
where you went or I see why you do I see
what's happening inside your mind or the
way you feel or how it relates to your
life
this is absent in most discourse on
television it's absent in all talk shows
it's like what we're talking about that
the oddness of a panel show I mean
they're so bizarre it doesn't make any
sense that none of it it's not how human
beings interact with each other
do you imagine if every conversation you
had in your life there was an audience
clapping or wooing at everything you
said you'd I mean it creates this sort
of fake way of communication that has
become so commonplace with us you just
even the way they sit sitting next to
each other like this like we're not
looking at each other I would be sitting
over here and you'd be at the desk and I
believe well Hamilton funny you bring
that up but you know and then look at
the crowd it's just it's it's alien I
mean it's really weird and I think
because of the fact that people are so
addicted to their phones and addicted to
media and this constant influx of this
loop of information and mean if you
watch the news they can't just give you
the [ __ ] news you have to get that
scroll on the bottom of other [ __ ] that
you should be freaking out about it's
like the news itself snot enough know
you have to know about terrorist attacks
and [ __ ] Isis and some new flu that
can't be cured and it's all scroll
on the bottom while you're watching
other shed we this is not how human
beings are designed
we're designed to talk we're designed to
communicate with each other person to
person this is what we're good at
this is what we're we've lost and the
one thing that has probably led to more
people understanding more about each
other the actual conversations is rare
which is really weird you're it's way
more common for someone to look at their
phone for 10 hours a day than it is for
someone to have a one-on-one
uninterrupted conversation with someone
for an hour those don't exist they exist
with lovers that's it with lovers and
occasionally with did if you have polite
dinner companions that put their phone
down and just drink a glass of wine and
talk to you about stuff but even then
people suck at it people are it's almost
like people forgot how to do it they
talk over each other they don't listen
to each other when the other person is
talking they're just waiting their turn
and talk it's a we're we're going down
weird roads that these roads where we
are sort of distancing ourselves from
compassion and understanding and real
communication absolutely I don't want to
about dear
psychedelics might help that's what I'm
10
that's what I'm saying hey I think they
would help I think if we had like real
centers where you could go and just like
you could go to a place where you can
get a licensed therapist to massage you
you know hey I've got this back Pole and
you know the only thing that works is
deep tissue massage you go to a place
they give you a robe they play nice
music they give you team and they're
there setting the set and the the
setting and the the the ambience of the
room it enhances the experience of
getting the massage when you go into the
room the lights are down they might have
a candle lit you know there's some
[ __ ] hot rocks in the place and
they're playing beautiful harp music in
the background the set and setting is a
part of the experience of getting a
massage if we can have something like
that and have these things common for
the use of psychedelics where you could
go to a an actual some sort of therapist
that's trained in both psychotherapy and
the use of psychedelics so they could
talk to you and find out if you're
stable ask you questions about your
medical history what kind of medications
are you're on and how you feeling what
are you trying to achieve through this
and then work you through an experience
I think this could be enormous ly
beneficial enormous event sure it
already has been I mean that's you know
we keep talking about psychedelic
medicine all the time but so much of
this has been done that's the really
crazy thing ibogaine used to be a
pharmaceutical in France although was
used at lower doses that weren't
psychedelic there used to be an MDMA
using it for as like a tonic to
stimulate people it was called Lam
Berean eight milligram tablets what is
an effective dose threshold
psychoactivity in my experience is about
20 milligrams of the hydrochloride salt
so they were micro dosing they were they
were mini micro dose and mini micro
dosing ibogaine they may have used
multiple tablets I don't know if anyone
is familiar with French historical
literature relating to ibogaine I have a
little bit of it but there isn't
I mean again they used to use a
psychedelic called endo pan as an
antidepressant in the Soviet Union in
the United States there was a drug
called Monet's alpha ethyl tryptamine
was used as an antidepressant it's an
MDMA type serotonin really sir and then
of course the whole history of DPT
facilitated end-of-life therapy LSD
psychotherapy on and on everything
Shogun's group did using two CB MMD a
ibogaine this was along with claudia
Naranjo in order to facilitate
psychotherapy I mean people not only
were doing it they were exploring all
the different ways to do it which
compounds are best for which
applications hmm do you have any
experience with cacao yes what what is
your experience in terms of the
psychedelic effects or psychoactive
effects it's mildly stimulating because
of the theobromine content but does it
mirror a small dose of MDMA or not in my
experience no this is what was it was
Kyle that was talking about that right
Kyle Kingsbury he was saying that in
large doses that raw cacao has some sort
of a mild MDMA like effect I've heard
people say that and people will
sometimes say that the presence of
phenylalanine in cacao could account for
that but it's it's such a small amount
raise quantities less than a milligram
and the active dose of finesse women is
hundreds of milligrams or grams in order
to achieve a psychoactive effect so I
think the effect that people do
experience is probably mediated by
theobromine which is present in in
relatively high quantities that's how
the you know it's named after the genus
Theobroma and theobromine does what how
does it make you feel it's just it's a
caffeine type stimulant so when people
say that chocolate contains caffeine
what they they're really referring to
theobromine and is that why it's deadly
to dogs yes it is huh
so it's theobromine that's doing it yep
fascinating so it's not actually
caffeine no this is a caffeine like
substance it's less potent than caffeine
what was your experience like physically
how did you feel when you took this this
cacao and what not what helped well how
large dose I mean I eat it every day
like raw
yeah but pound it's the powder yeah you
did every day and yogurt and just as a
health thing yeah as a health thing and
I liked the the flavor of it but I have
never had an experience beyond at most a
low-level stimulant experience and I've
also taken pure theobromine and is
stimulating but it requires like 500
milligrams to achieve an effect if I
remember correctly hmm um what others
what about um you ever [ __ ] with nutmeg
nobody I mean it's a fascinating area of
course you know prisoners historically
did it Malcolm X did it yeah and the
essential oil of nutmeg contains maryska
Tsin which is a precursor for the
psychedelic amphetamine mm DEA not MDMA
but it's methoxy MDA
and as well as LM Eason which is another
psychedelic precursor as well as there's
I think one other maybe even safrole
actually I think it's safrole LM Eason
and maryska sin' and Shulgin had a
hypothesis again shelygin was actually
by training a biochemist not a organic
chemist although he spent his career
doing organic chemistry so he was very
interested in these ideas of the body
creating psychedelics so he thought when
you consume nutmeg oil that your body is
is emanating this double bond and
creating a series of different
amphetamines and that's what it counts
for the high but in reality people don't
actually know whoa yeah
hmm so what kind of history of use the
does it have in terms of like people
taking it for the psychoactive benefits
I'm sure there is some ancient your I it
would be I would assume there is some
ancient use of it but you know it's
mostly like thing for teenagers and
people in prison these days it's kind of
what it's illegal hi it's one of these
things that you do when you don't have
access to to anything else it's and most
of the reports make it sound more like
an anticholinergic deliriant type
experience more like taking a lot of
Dramamine than like a classical
psychedelic experience but you can use
that oil to make a lot of psychedelics
in a laboratory Wow no history of use is
also so fascinating to me when you talk
about history of use because there are
certain cultures that really don't have
a written history they have oral history
so it's very difficult to determine when
people started
what about peyote what is the history of
use of peyote because I remember reading
something that kind of stunned me that
said that there's only like a couple
hundred years of known use of peyote
yeah okay so there's different histories
because peyote is used it grows
naturally over a relatively broad region
stretching from the southern United
States into I believe mostly northern
Mexico and so in the United States the
history is about a hundred years old of
the Native American church it's recent
but that's crazy so 1918 something like
that yes it was a Comanche chief name
Quanah Parker who spread the peyote
religion across the United States and it
caught on because it's fantastic of
course it caught on I never experienced
it what does a lot well again it's
another one of these plants that has
mescal and of course but then it has
these other accessory alkaloids that
modulate the experience of what's really
interesting about peyote is it contains
this chemical called peyote and peyote
in it I have some pharmacy trade
journals from like 1890 or something
like that no it must be later than that
it must
maybe like 1915 or something like that
sometime around there and they talk
about like your pharmacy must have
morphine cocaine and peyote
the three substances every pharmacist
needs and and peyote was used as a
hypnotic it was used to induce sleep but
there's been no very little research on
it none in the twenty-first century I
mean this is like was once considered a
really valuable medicine the issues that
it's a little bit tricky to synthesize
and it has to be extracted from this
rare cactus LaFave for a diffuse' but
but that modulates the experience you
have so many different alkaloids and and
it it's very long-lasting it causes
dramatic pupil dilation it's extremely
nauseating embalm i made an episode
about peyote in the most recent season
of my show and i vomited so much that my
nose started bleeding you know it was
some serious vomiting and it's
physically very very punishing more so
than almost anything I've ever done in
terms of the after-effects or while
you're doing it while you're doing it
it's it's a heavy load on the body um so
it's people always say this is not
recreational or whatever but it's truly
isn't so you know this is really um a
punishing experience and on top of that
the Native American ceremonies often
accentuate some of those punishing
aspects of it like water is conserved
you don't get to drink as much water as
you want but to emphasize the importance
of water in Mazatec salvia ceremonies
there's no water at all which i think is
actually increases the absorption of the
leaf into your mouth because the natural
reaction when you eat something
disgusting is to wash it down with water
these are little things that people do
impulsively without thinking that are
going to change the nature of the
experience so anyway you eat this cactus
it's incredibly nauseating and bitter
and then you have maybe a 12 hour
hallucinatory euphoric state that's very
beautiful and strange no you see the
cactus raw yeah some people grind it
some people cook it so that's cactus you
could get that [ __ ] at Home Depot you
can get San Pedro at home
no no peyote is a dumpling cactus it's a
very small somewhat spherical cactus
that produces beautiful white and pink
flowers and it's incredibly slow growing
which is why the conservation of peyote
is an even bigger issue than the
conservation of toads I mean peyote all
these psychedelic plants have major
conservation issues that need to be
addressed but peyote is arguably the
biggest of them all because this is a
slow growing plant if you want to learn
patience grow peyote that is how you
learn I mean this this bottle cap I mean
it would take five years before it's the
size of a dime if you grow it from seed
yes so when you're eating something
that's you know that's as big as the
column of a coffee mug or something like
that it might be 20-30 years old Jesus
Christ so there's a lot of history in
these plants they call them grandfather
peyote and I think the reason is that by
the time that they're ready to be
consumed they often are grandfathers or
grandmothers they have produced seeds
and have offspring and all this stuff
because it takes that long so yes it's
very slow growing it's not a sustainable
practice the way that it's being done
but there's also even bigger threats to
the environment in the form of Route
ploughing all of the territory to build
Walmart's and subdivisions and different
things in South Texas because most of
that land is privately owned and and
it's difficult because there's a belief
in the Native American church that has
to be an outdoor natural grown it can't
be a green house cultivated plant
because part of the potency and the
value is from its interaction with
nature so it's it's if it's sustainably
harvested where only the crown of the
cactus is removed with this long carrot
like tap root is left in the soil it can
regenerate new heads but if people don't
have proper harvesting techniques it can
decimate the population very quickly
especially because it's not a very
potent substance it requires many of
these ultra ultra ultra slow growing
plants Wow
so what is the natural territory of it
how wide is the natural tear
taury of these plants I can't tell you
exactly but it's not very large so if it
got very popular there'd be a real
problem yeah it probably won't I mean
you know the people that care most about
it outside of the Native American church
are interestingly kakda files in
Thailand in Japan who grow it for purely
aesthetic purposes because it's so
beautiful they and they would never even
consider it because to them it's this
prized ornamental plant that produces
amazing fruit and flowers and lives
seemingly forever and if you take care
of it it can just look amazing
so those there's a huge peyote scene in
Thailand of people that never would
dream of consuming it that just grow it
ornamentally Wow now San Pedro cactus
does that have psychoactive properties
absolutely yes and did you have to
extract in a different way like peyote
it can be consumed raw with some
varieties of San Pedro they actually
contain comparable quantities of
mescaline to peyote and it's a much more
sustainable source of mescaline for that
reason it grows unlike peyote it grows
very very quickly and and can be
propagated by cutting easily and it you
know it's much easier to work with but
traditionally if you go to Peru they'll
take a length of the cactus and they'll
cut it like a loaf of bread into slices
then they boil those slices and create a
sort of low potency aqueous infusion
that they drink and what's interesting
about the way they do it is that it
seems that it's almost designed to
create a lower potency drink the way
they do it they drink every night the
shamans every night of their entire life
and many people come back and do it
repeatedly and for them it's sort of
it's like a traditional form of micro
dosing you could say it's not about
blasting yourself into the cosmos the
way people do when they spoke DMT this
is about fortifying your body giving
yourself strength cleansing yourself
balancing yourself and are there people
that consume it raw as well
not that I saw there no hmm oh but
people do what people do I have and what
is the effect is it comparable to the
peyote effect
it's comparable but it's yeah it's
comparable but again it's very hard
because of these variations with natural
it's all just in terms of the potency of
the cactus and that point in your life
and you know people will always come up
to me and say what's the deal with MDMA
it used to be like this and now it's
like this what accounts for that it's
like well don't underestimate your own
changes over time when I was 21 I could
drink alcohol not that I did very often
but I could and not want to kill myself
the next day now if I try to drink more
than three drinks I'm gonna feel
horrible the next day I'm just
emotionally ruined and that's me not
alcohol now you brought up the term
hypnotic and which made me remind it
reminded me of our conversation that we
had through email about Roseanne Barr oh
yeah yeah right oh yes of course yes and
about ambien
yeah and about the effects of ambien she
came on the show she still hasn't um she
can't she's having a really hard time
with this she feels terrible about what
she said she feels like the whole world
hates her she feels like she's lost
everything and her life is destroyed and
she's distraught and she she was going
to fly out here but we had a
conversation and we kind of decided to
be probably better if she waited just
let let some of this pass by it's still
in the news because they've decided to
move the show on without her there
they're gonna kill her off or something
man
yeah and she's just devastated and you
know she was also devastated health-wise
physically she's an older woman and not
that it been any different she was an
older man she's an older person and this
grueling schedule of doing a television
show was horrible on her it just it was
really really tough to do she got
bronchitis she felt like she was almost
dying she was completely exhausted and
she felt like the schedule of it all
just was just way too taxing on her
physically then on top of that she's on
a
host of different things she's I mean
she'll if we ever do wind up sitting
down and talking on the podcast I'll get
her to list the various thing she's on
but she's on various antidepressants
that she changes him up
mixes him up she was one of the things
she said to me she's she needs to get
her doses readjusted she drinks alcohol
regularly she smokes marijuana regularly
she's also on ambien regularly takes it
every night to go to sleep and I tried
to explain to her the fact that you're
not getting real sleep when you're on
that this is not something you should
take and rely on on a daily basis they
even tell you to get off of it I mean
it's it's and it's difficult to get off
of it but people want to dismiss the
idea that she could have said something
that's completely out of character or
done something that's completely out of
character while under the influence of
this stuff that it could have
contributed to that they want to dismiss
it because they want a villain they want
you know no she's bad they want this
like this childlike simplistic reasoning
and rationalization for what she's done
right and this is you know a prime
example of this sort of schizophrenic
nature of the way drugs are depicted in
our society if it's if it's something
like bath salts or k2 they're
responsible for everything one toke of
that stuff and you're eating your best
friend's face under a bridge but then in
Roseanne's case they have no explanation
whatsoever no exploratory value they
can't be used to explain anything
is it an excuse no is it an explanation
I think yes I think that intoxication
can explain all sorts of inappropriate
behavior and to pretend otherwise is
again dishonest I know and Sanofi the
pharmaceutical company that manufactures
ambien had this widely shared tweet
saying that racism is in a side effect
of ambien but it's a little bit
ridiculous for them to have done that
you know especially to someone who's
mentally ill because you know if you
look at the medical literature the fact
of the matter is that ambien is
associated with all sorts of absurd
hey viewers command hallucinations where
people stab themselves jump out windows
people that you know butter their
cigarettes and smoke them people that
paint their houses in the middle of the
night with no memory whatsoever and it's
a profoundly profoundly disinhibited
drug so you know here's maybe a somewhat
analogous example from my own life I
never take ambien on planes for this
reason because I'm around strangers I
don't know what I'm gonna say or what
I'm gonna do let alone use Twitter but I
don't it's uncomfortable because it's so
disinhibited I might do something weird
I don't know take off my shirt I have no
idea you who's to predict what you're
gonna do when you have no inhibitions
whatsoever so I remember once I was on
the plane to Berlin and I did take
ambien and I start in a sort of
delusional state thinking that the cabin
crew and the person that's announcing
over the intercom is saying various Nazi
things that's like an unfair stereotype
that all Germans are Nazis that's
offensive but I had no control over this
like just because they're German talking
in German doesn't mean that this is like
a Nazi airship because you're just
completely out of your mind
Wow but again I mean I'll another story
I used to be friends with a girl whose
dad was a psychiatrist prescribed her
immense quantities of ambien and she
would snort it there's no reason to
start it it's water-soluble has a fast
onset of action there's no benefit and
snorting it it's fine orally if you're
gonna take it at all there's no reason
to take high doses it's already a
deliriant at the therapeutic dose you
don't need to take more even five
milligrams induces delirium but but I
remember that I was at some party and
someone was saying that they wanted
ketamine and didn't at the party of
ketamine and just a complete stranger
and I said oh I actually have a little
bit of ketamine but it's at my apartment
here are the keys and here's my address
and just run over to my apartment and
greet it and help yourself talk to you
later
and and then I'm one of these people
I've never lost my phone never lost my
keys I don't lose things so then I you
know wake up the next morning go to my
apartment reach into my pocket my keys
are gone and then it hits me this flash
of oh my god
I gave my keys away to a complete
stranger to go to my apartment and take
ketamine from me what on earth was I
thinking what like what level of
disinhibition is required to do
something that insane luckily I was
there had to spend the rest of the day
tracing finding out who that person was
getting my keys and these people happen
to be very courteous people and actually
did go to my apartment did take the
small amount of ketamine that I had and
then just lock the door after themselves
and didn't make a mess but again I mean
this is it like this is a profoundly
disinhibited substance and also I think
the idea that a drug couldn't modulate
racist activities interesting as well
because there's a study that you can
look up where they use the beta blocker
propranolol and they found that it
actually seems to block racial implicit
racial bias in people in certain tests
that what they're suggesting is that
there's an a drone or jet component to
implicit racial bias but there's a
certain maybe heart rate or fear
response and once that's physiologically
blocked you become less racist in a
sentence implicitly it's not a conscious
decision conscious racism is introduced
but an implicit racial bias is I mean
these are like really complicated
higher-level questions about how drugs
impact cognitive functioning and and the
bottom line I think is be careful as
being certain about anything about what
drugs can or can't do what does this
Jamie oh this is this story blood
pressure drug reduces inbuilt what does
that word inbuilt racism common heart
disease drug may have an unusual side
effect of combating racism
well isn't that a [ __ ] that was that
stupid movie with Jack Nicholson and
Helen Hunt as good as it gets
he was a racist and they gave him a pill
they gave him some medication and
reduced racism it stopped him from being
racist oh I completely forgot I remember
it because I was angry because a bunch
of people from the I was working on
television show at this time bunch of
people were talking about how great a
movie it was because it was
weird dark sort of film and I was like
that movie [ __ ] sucked it was so
depressing here this woman she's got you
know she's like a waitress and Jack
Nicholson is this old racist [ __ ] and
she's relying on him for some real
reason because she can't find a new one
who's nice to her and and he's racist
but the the the the resolve of the film
was that he just was sick and they gave
him some medication he wasn't racing
anymore I'm like get the [ __ ] out of
here that doesn't make any sense
meanwhile maybe it does I mean ambien is
an amazing amazing substance I made a
piece about it called the ambient effect
years ago I don't know if you're
familiar they're people who are
paralyzed who can take ambien and start
walking again it has the power to
regenerate regions of the to regenerate
activity in regions of the brain that
look dead on fMRI it is a wacky drug
it's also chemically very similar to
5-methyl DMT it's it's not it's not like
a benzodiazepine like valium it has its
own bizarre structure I mean it's a
weird drug so when these people are
paralyzed why they paralyzed like what
what is wrong with the strokes traumatic
brain injury various reasons there's a
book about it called hope and brain
damage I believe the title of it is an
ambien somehow another temporarily fixes
it yes
temper only for the duration of the drug
effects so there's people that are in a
you know persistent vegetative state
they take ambien and suddenly they wake
up what the [ __ ] yes yeah it's pretty
it's well documented and it's a really
bizarre effect that is exclusively
present in ambien and maybe slightly in
baclofen as well yeah I thought that the
the statement that the pharmaceutical
company made about racism not being a
side effect was kind of cute it's kind
of witty yeah it was a very snarky yes
but the problem with that [ __ ] is well
what are the side effects and then you
go into the actual side effects you're
like holy [ __ ] how is this legal and
then you go into the side-effects of
like what is this doing to people like
well yeah here's another one it
supposedly increases consolidation of
negative memories whoa yeah there's a
lot of weird
stuff- memory increases consolidation of
negative memories causes just total
hallucinatory insanity at higher doses
may be the most powerful disinhibited
I'm aware of and is able to restore
cognitive and motor functioning and
people with traumatic brain injuries
what a weird drug very weird and not not
something people should be taking every
day just not it's certainly addictive I
mean it binds to even though it's not a
benzodiazepine itself it binds to the
benzodiazepine site on the GABA a
receptor but yes no it's addictive it's
super addictive so for that reason alone
people shouldn't be taking it every day
because you'll become horrendously
dependent on it and withdrawal is
ruthless yet withdrawal is total
insomnia
so most people just go right back to it
or you know you can then Trant like you
can transition onto different types of
hypnotics like taking an anticholinergic
like benadryl to sleep or cannabinoids
cannabis things like that or you know
just things that don't bind to the GABA
a receptor in order to try to reduce
tolerance there's ways around it you're
not doomed if you start taking it but
it's it's certainly habit forming and
something that's best to avoid if you
don't require it and it doesn't give you
real sleep correct I mean you're you're
missing some part of the sleep cycle dr.
Matthew Walker was on here as a sleep
specialist and he went into depth about
it but I really don't remember his exact
description but he was talking about how
it bypasses certain cycles and you're
not getting a real night's sleep I I'm
not aware of that I mean there's
wouldn't surprise me hugely you know
there's still debate about what the most
restful part of sleep is I think most
literature points to actually non REM
sleep
slow-wave sleep being the most restful
type and that's actually supported or
promoted by chemicals like musk amol
from the Amanita muscaria mushroom mmm
and there was one pharmaceutical
derivative called GAO box at all that i
did an episode about on the most recent
season of my show and that really does
produce incredibly restful sleep that is
superior to ambien but like ambien it
was also psychedelic even more
psychedelic probably so this is an issue
it seems that for whatever reason a lot
of these drugs that really promote sleep
effectively also happened to be
hallucinogenic and nobody knows exactly
why but it's been a pharmaceutical
barrier because we don't live in a
culture that allows people to go nuts at
night yeah no kidding
I'm glad you brought up to MIT to
muscaria because that's another one that
is almost like a drug of lore more than
a drug of application you don't really
hear too much about people getting real
good experiences no you don't but it's
also connected to
you know the sacred mushroom in the
cross the cover of it from gianmarco
Allegro has dynamic Amanita muscaria he
thought that the Amanita muscaria was
probably linked to psychedelic states
and prehistoric christianity we we don't
know right oh he's such a salacious
wacky guy was he
oh yeah yeah absolutely I mean he he was
getting off on it he loved it he would
love getting off on freaking people out
of freaking out Christian that was a you
can't underestimate what he was saying
he was saying all of Christianity is a
sex cult that worships a fungal phallus
and the semen of that phallus are the
spores yeah that all of Christianity is
an ancient fertility cult that's a big
claim from a serious oxford-educated
Dead Sea scroll scholar who's respected
up until that point yeah who was also an
ordained minister yeah I mean there's a
great book called shroom that argues
that this was all some kind of cynical
attack on the Christian religion and
that he didn't even believe it himself
the issue is that in order to carefully
examine his claims you need to speak
what is it ancient Aramaic or something
so it's like it doesn't I'm not in a
position reading his book which is all
having to do with etymology of these
words there are origins and different
languages I just don't know enough about
these ancient languages to make an
informed assessment of his claims but
which is I think one reason that they've
kind of hung around in this lore for
such a long time because it's hard for
people to say with certainty if they're
true or not although I leaned to them
toward them probably not being well
supported
big pause why is that just seems too
wacky yeah because they're not I haven't
seen them integrated into any serious
work since not that's necessarily a good
argument it to take a lot of Education
to be able to even understand whether or
not that debate is cogent right right
it's the same deal I encounter this
sometimes on like really fringe aspects
of physics and chemistry where someone
will make some kind of wacky argument
about the way atoms bond or something
like that and it's like it's it gets
hard because you only have like a small
handful of people that are capable of
seriously evaluating the claims able to
weigh in and then it doesn't really get
vetted in a serious way so things just
linger around is maybe it's true maybe
it's not but but the bottom line is that
most people don't get a valuable
experience from these mushrooms but some
do some people figured out how to make
it work and the experiences again it's
you know it's its own thing it's a
GABAergic deliriant it takes you into a
dreamy drunk zone yeah and it's it's in
many ways a toxin right it's toxic in
some forms but well it contains another
chemical a botanic acid that is
potentially very toxic although it
hasn't really been examined in fact it
also contains a complex of this element
of vanadium that could potentially be
toxic as well so there are some
legitimate toxicity concerns that I
think anyone who's consuming it should
be aware of you know the ideal situation
would be isolated Mosca mole but it's
hard to extract hmm and but yet it's
connected in so much artwork and so so
much ancient depictions of this
particularly of Christmas cards there's
always elves and these little Amanita
muscaria caps right well drugs aside you
have to acknowledge that it's a
spectacularly beautiful mushroom as
amazed you I've gone mushroom hunting
all over the world and there is no
question that when you see that mushroom
in habitat that it's completely
spectacular there's nothing else like it
it is magical experience just looking at
it yeah I ran across it only more
in Colorado in the woods and it was
amazing it's like this bit was a big one
- it's big beautiful red with white dots
on it it's like one of the most gorgeous
things you could ever see growing yeah
yeah and it's legal right you you're
it's legal to possess again yes it's
legal because it's you know anything
enjoyable for most people but is it
possible that we just are doing it wrong
and that the the information has been
lost as to how to cuz a lot of people
felt like it might have been a part of
soma which hasn't really been defined as
to what soma is right
yeah those those debates are not really
my my cup of tea Rhys it's like just
tons of guys pushing this or that
argument without like a lot of evidence
one way or the other and so I don't know
and then there's people that argue that
you're in drinking somehow yeah wired to
concentrate the muscum all in one way or
another you know if you want to learn
about it I think the best way to do it
is actually through this other related
drug a box at all which was almost
developed by Merck as a competitor for
ambien and there's some high dose
reports of gobblox at all that give you
a much clearer example and from my own
experience as well of what the potential
of that class is and it's very different
it's every bit as powerful as ayahuasca
or something like that but completely
different hmm
and it's hard to articulate all these
things are hard to articulate but it's
something that's been experienced by
relatively few people so you don't even
have this spiritual or metaphorical
vocabulary for it the way that I had it
most powerfully was once I was doing a
shoot for Vice on HBO and they told me I
had to go to Tokyo with it less than 24
hours notice and that I had to start
filming as soon as the plane landed
couldn't go to the hotel room so I
thought alright this is serious no
messing around no time for jet lag like
I've got a fall asleep 10:00 p.m. that
night wake up at 8 a.m. that morning
I've got to be awake all day so I'm
gonna pharmacologically force this a
little bit I'm gonna take a really high
dose of this muscum old derivative at
night to induce sleep and I'll take
adderall during the day that was the
plan so I took a high dose I believe it
was 45
milligrams but don't quote me on that of
this Moscow mole derivative that's about
the same potency and at the equivalent
of what would have been maybe 2 p.m. New
York time which I think was crucial
because these things are hypnotic they
induce sleep so if you take it during
the day you're less likely to sleep
through the whole experience and it was
unbelievable
I mean I I I couldn't fathom the
intensity of what I experienced it was
you know just this rushing sense of
becoming a passive observer in my own
consciousness and seeing all of my
thoughts
produced by someone else that were
racing at a speed that was so fast that
I found it physically dizzying and had
to lay down and I felt as if like the
acceleration was pushing me toward an
ultimate state that was sleep and that
sleep and death represented the ultimate
state of consciousness whoa
so it was it was and then and then I had
to wake up I didn't work the next day
and if people say how did you sleep it's
like well I actually had this
transformative existential trip
accidentally but but but have you tried
it since just purposely for I mean a
couple of times yeah did you ever
recreate that kind of experience no
because it was it was a bit much I would
say and I know people that have taken
even more and you know it turns into
just your entire visual field
transforming into rotating cubes where
each face of the cube represents a
different aspect of your life your
future your past your present you know
really dramatic stuff so I think that
potential exists with high-dose muscum
all it's just hard for people to ingest
it because of all the other material in
the mushroom and the disgustingness
mm-hmm consuming it so is it possible
that we've just just much like people
have sort of altered many different
things like wheat and tomatoes and
what-have-you that at one point Tom the
mushroom was somehow different oh yeah
well yes absolutely yeah I mean the
evolutionary chemical history of all
these different plants is a fascinating
subject that's pretty much lost to
history you know there's no like
archaeological alkaloid analysis that
I'm aware of but it would be so
fascinating to know because all these
natural products evolved just like the
plants that contain them what were the
intermediate materials what drugs have
gone extinct have did our ancestors
drive certain psychoactive plants to
extinction there's a plan called
Silphium that some people have argued
that may have happened with it was a
phenyl derivative or like a phenol
related plant but yeah I mean it's it's
really and we've seen it with cannabis
you know the black-market encouraged
everyone to produce THC dominant strains
because it was the most potent most
stoning most bang for your buck you know
now we have the ability to change the
evolutionary direction of the plant and
to encourage the production of CBN or
CBG or THC V or CBD or whatever hmm so
when you talk about a plant like the
peyote cactus that grows so incredibly
slow and you know if if that became
something that was highly sought after
and very very valuable it could
conceivably be wiped out yes
yeah especially something really slow so
there could have been substances like
that that we're very geographically
local at a very small area they're just
gone yeah it's just a thought I just had
totally non evidence-based but it
wouldn't be crazy if a lot of the reason
that a lot of these psychoactive plants
that are present today tend to be less
addictive it's because all the addictive
ones were harvested to extinction
thousands of years ago maybe something
like that I mean these things do happen
if I guess it didn't wouldn't no we
really wouldn't have any way of knowing
but if they're fossilized plants right
right it certainly didn't happen with
coca which contains cocaine or riot-- so
it probably didn't happen that way but
you know you just don't know yeah and I
had read some theories that it's
conceivable that the Amanita muscaria
very seasonably so you have to figure
out like when is the right time to
harvest it because there are some plants
although of course fungus isn't really a
plant it's kind of the opposite of a
plan the way in ingest oxygen it takes
in carbon it takes in oxygen and breathe
out carbon dioxide like a like an animal
does but that it's possible that these
things very seasonably that you have to
catch them within a window of time and
that they also vary geographically like
some places they might be more potent
like you know Cuban cigars growing on
specific land have a distinctly more
you know more potent taste to them oh
yeah absolutely because the biosynthetic
precursors for all of these natural
products come from the soil typically
you know amino acids and things like
that and and it's all going to to change
there was an amazing experiment that was
done where they started doping the
substrate of psilocybin containing
mushrooms with other tryptamines so they
used instead of these det and dipt put
it in the substrate and they found that
the mushroom would take that completely
synthetic chemical that does not occur
in nature it would then for hydroxylate
the indole ring just like it were a
silicon derivative and create natural
product derivatives of these synthetic
materials creating these semi synthetic
hybrids between man and mushroom
creations Jesus yeah yeah I mean this is
like why the synthetic natural dichotomy
doesn't make sense
everything is evolving it's a constant
interplay between human and plant and
fungus
you know after we're all gone all of our
plastic bottles are going to be consumed
by some bacterium that evolves to
degrade all of these you know polymers
and that will create natural products
from them and will those natural
products be natural products because
they were derived from a substrate that
we created you know it turns into like a
very complicated issue which is why I
don't believe in the idea of natural and
synthetic everything is simultaneously
natural and simultaneously synthetic
well everything comes from Earth yes so
even the most unnatural things that
human beings have created or and
essential natural creations like a bee
creates a beehive a beehive is a natural
creation right yeah it's a mindfuck so
to get back to Amanita muscaria do you
know of anyone who's effectively
regularly used it as a psychedelic yes
I've met but not people who I whack e
people yeah I would imagine yeah yeah
people would say oh that guy's a
professor and he uses Amanita every
night he's doing really well but yes
wacky people there's so much lore again
attached to it specifically because the
Christian I mean the books by Allegro
we're big right one of them was the Dead
Sea Scrolls and the Christian myth it
was one of his books and that was the
second book that he published after the
sacred mushroom in the cross I think he
did that because they took the sacred
mushroom in the cross off the market
right like what didn't the catholic
church buy out the rights for that or
was that a myth as well i can't remember
something along those lines but Yohn
Irvan republished it fairly recently
with the blessings of the allegro family
but the the just that the whole
connection to Santa Claus and the whole
connection to Christmas with that
mushroom it's there's so much attached
to that mushroom people want that
mushroom to be Jesus there that's the
one you know that's the way it's the
prettiest it's like it grows it's got a
micro Reiser relationship with
coniferous trees so you find it
underneath pine trees just like the
shiny presents underneath the Christmas
tree so people get so excited about that
mushroom yes they do but yet no one gets
off on it except wacky people yeah it's
it's a complicated situation and you
know just because something's convenient
isn't a good reason to say that it's the
truth like there are other psychoactive
mushrooms that may have been used in the
past they're ones that we've discovered
recently there's a species called roto
kaliba Immaculata as far as I know
there's no information about humans
consuming this mushroom but it contains
a Salvadoran a type Kappa opioid agonist
this could be a completely different
type of psychedelic mushroom no
information on it exists maybe someone
used it somewhere in the past I don't
know whoa
well isn't there there are some
psychedelic substances that have been
discovered that have no history of human
use like isn't Hawaiian baby Woodrow's
as I would how you say it yeah doesn't
have LST like properties but no history
of human use that's a complicated
question yeah there's maybe not with
Hawaiian baby woodrose but with Morning
Glory seeds there does seem to be some
Mesoamerican history although it's not
as well founded and Morning Glory seeds
will put you on the moon right well they
yeah they contain LSA and again allas a
is actually the Albert Hofmann did is
the inventor of Elysee did an experiment
where he injected himself with small
quantities of LSA but there aren't many
evaluations of the pure material so the
exact nature of the different components
in those seeds remains a little bit
mysterious as far as I'm concerned some
people will suggest that it's the
strongest naturally-occurring
psychedelic other people will say that
it's not even psychedelic at all that
it's just a hypnotic it just has a sort
of sedating quality I've used Hawaiian
baby Woodrow's many many years ago and
it's certainly psychoactive whether I
would call it classically psychedelic is
a complicated issue it's kind of like a
dreamy unpleasant delirium hmm
any other ones that we could go that are
weird watch my show I think you'd really
like it I'm sure I'd like it I like all
your stuff okay because it goes into
lots of weird so I just don't have
enough time I know I to many things yeah
that are cool now yeah that's one of the
problems with Netflix and HBO and
YouTube and just just too much cool
stuff yeah
but this will be cool I will definitely
watch it okay ah that was three hours
men just flew by Wow not crazy that is
crazy time warp over here so Wow listen
this is way better than the first time
we did it we were here I think got a lot
of cool information now and I really
appreciate you coming back man thanks
for how secure do this again but not in
seven years - quicker yes I hope so sure
thank you and on Twitter and Instagram
it's Hamilton Morris and your show is
Hamilton's pharmacopoeia it's is it
available online because people watch it
online yes it's on Hulu and streaming on
Amazon and streaming on iTunes and it's
on vice land as well so no phone yeah
all right easy to find
thanks man that was awesome appreciating
[Music]
[Music]